bonjour à tous à suivre dans un instant
le début de l'examen au sénat du projet
de loi qui vise à renforcer l'efficacité
des sanctions pénales en clair de la
réforme pénale de christiane taubira un
texte examiné en procédure accélérée qui
a été adopté au début du mois de juin
par l'assemblée nationale et dont
l'examen a débuté hier soir au sénat
alors la mesure phare de ce projet de
loi c'est la contrainte pénal une peine
de probation en clair une peine qui se
déroule non pas en prison mais en milieu
ouvert qui peut être prononcée pour un
certain nombre des lits une peine
assortie elle d'obligations et de tout
un suivi pour les condamnés la semaine
dernière les sénateurs ont durci le
texte sur ce point puisque à
l'initiative du rapporteur socialiste
jean pierre michel ils ont fait de cette
contrainte pénale la seule peine qui
puisse être prononcée par le juge dans
un certain nombre de petits délits comme
le vol simple par exemple ou encore la
filouterie ce changement a donc un petit
peu retendu le débat avant l'examen du
texte au sénat examen qui a débuté hier
lorsque nous avons pu assister à la
discussion générale qui a débuté par le
discours de christiane taubira
christiane taubira excellente oratrice
qui a fait tout un discours sur
l'histoire du droit pénal avec de
nombreuses références philosophiques
littéraires et sociologique tout de
suite donc retour à cette séance hier
soir au sénat
monsieur le président monsieur le
président de la commission des lois
monsieur le rapporteur
mesdames dessinatrice messieurs les
sénateurs
le texte dont nous allons débattre et
qui a déjà été enrichi par les travaux
de l'assemblée nationale et par votre
commission des lois sous l'impulsion de
votre rapporteur jean-pierre michel est
un texte de protection de la société
puisqu'il vise en premier lieu de
renforcer la sécurité des français mais
vous conviendrez sans doute et très
volontiers avec moi que la sécurité ne
peut pas constituer l'horizon la
démocratie les phénomènes de déviants
sont inhérents à toute organisation
sociale et il serait illusoire de
prétendre à une société qui ne
connaîtraient aucune forme de
délinquance
ces phénomènes de déviance sont prises
en charge par la société et c'est un des
grands enseignements que nous tenons
d'emile durkheim qui considérait que la
capacité d'une société à régler les
conflits en 105 s'exprime par le bien
par excellence ce qui veut dire que
l'idéal de sécurité totale est un idéal
à la fois dangereux est trompeur il est
dangereux dans la mesure où il comporte
une limitation une restriction
potentiellement sans limites des droits
et des libertés il est trompeur en ce
qu'il prétend au qui laisse entendre
qu'on pourrait éliminer tous les risques
nous devons donc faire tout ce qui est
possible pour qu'il y ait le moins de
victimes possible et prendre en charge
en accompagnement ses victimes par le
devoir de solidarité qui leur est dû par
le corps social tout entier à travers
l'action de l'état mais nous ne pouvons
pas laisser croire que nous pouvons
éviter tout tout acte de délinquance
de la même façon nous devons faire vivre
et rendre effective ce devoir de
solidarité nous devons faire en sorte
aussi que les personnes qui ont feraient
la loi soient sanctionnés à la mesure de
l'acte qu'elles ont commis mais que leur
réinsertion dans le corps social soit
préparé ce sont ces deux exigences qui
ont inspiré ce texte de loi qui lui
conforte le contrat social dans la
mesure où il vise à protéger davantage
et mieux et a fermé le pacte républicain
par l'action de cohésion qui te propose
parce qu'il s'agit d'un sujet important
parce que c'est un sujet qui concerne
toute la société et parce que nous avons
le souci de réussir nous avons choisi
une méthode novatrice pour préparer ce
texte de loi que nous vous présentons
vous connaissez l'essentiel des travaux
pas conduit la conférence de consensus
qui a été mise en place et a travaillé
pendant ces mois j'ai eu la chance de
pouvoir mobiliser des personnes de très
grande qualité de sensibilité différente
de parcours différent des personnes qui
ont accepté malgré leurs divergences de
travailler ensemble et c'est ainsi que
le comité d'organisation a plus élaboré
un état des savoirs sur la prévention de
la récidive
à l'échelle nationale et internationale
qu'il a préparé les travaux de la du
jury de consensus et ce jury de
consensus qui a tenu deux audiences
publiques qui ont rassemblé 2300
personnes a retenu douze préconisations
les douze qui ont été votées à
l'unanimité au sein du jury nous a
soumis ses préconisations à partir
desquels jouvert moi-même trois cycles
de consultation et c'est le texte sorti
de ces consultations a fait l'objet
évidemment du processus habituel
c'est-à-dire des travaux
interministériels j'ai effectué par
ailleurs au tour de france afin
d'informer et de convaincre le plus
précisément possible et aujourd'hui nous
sommes devant vous avec un texte de loi
qui est passé déjà entre les mains de
l'assemblée nationale et je le disais à
l'instant entre les mains de votre
commission des lois et dont je ne doute
pas nous allait oeuvrer à l'enrichir
encore en séance plénière ces travaux
nous ont permis d'élaborer un état des
lieux le plus rigoureux possible parce
que nous avons choisi de travailler sur
la base des connaissances évaluer des
expériences qui ont été encadrés aussi
bien en france en europe que qu'en
amérique du nord et principalement au
canada et c'était à des lieux nous met
face à une impasse dans l'action et avec
un risque psychologique face à
l'impuissance publique d'abord sur la
méthode la méthode qui aboutit à cet
état des lieux et à ce bilan a consisté
d'abord en une inflation législative qui
par elle même d'ailleurs révélé par sa
propre spirale l'inefficacité des choix
qui avait été fait puisque à 33 reprises
la procédure pénale a été modifié ces
dix dernières années et 67 fois le droit
pénal a été modifié ensuite il ya eu une
politique du chiffre qui a exercé une
pression très forte sur les forces
denquête l'effort de sécurité de police
et de gendarmerie cette politique du
chiffre et cette pression ont été
dénoncées par les syndicats de police
eux mêmes il ya une déconnexion de la
politique pénale et de la politique
carcérale chacune d'une certaine façon
vivant sa vie chacune avec sa logique et
sa propre rationalité l'une avec sa
fureur d'une certaine façon est en tout
cas au moins avec ses excès et l'autre
avec son embolie de sorte qu'il a fallu
envisager des pis-aller et notamment des
automatismes dans la gestion des flux
carcéraux je pense notamment à la
procédure simplifiée d'aménagement de
peine ou à la surveillance électronique
de fin de peine afin d'essayer de
contenir les effets des automatismes
d'incarcération enfin autre point de la
méthode un élargissement du champ
contentieux en faisant entrer des actes
qui jusque-là relevait de contraventions
dans le champ délictuelle une
aggravation du de la durée des peines et
donc de la durée d'incarcération qui est
passé en moyenne ces dix dernières
années de 8 mois a enjoint avec
évidemment pour effet une augmentation
de la population carcérale une
augmentation de 35 % ce qui est sans
correspondance avec le taux
d'augmentation démographique qui a été
d'environ 7% sur la même période et ce
en relation aussi avec l'évolution des
taux de délinquance pour quel résultat
le premier résultat c'est que l'objectif
affiché de lutter contre la récidive n'a
pas été atteint puisque le taux de
condamnation pénale en récidive légale
est passé de 4,9 à eau à 12 1% sur la
même période c'est à dire de 2001 à 2011
ensuite cette surpopulation carcérale a
rendu compliqué le travail de
préparation à la sortie justement pour
prévenir la récidive il faut se souvenir
que 76% des personnes condamnées exécute
une peine de moins donnant 56% une peine
de moins de six mois c'est un délai
soupe trop court pour préparer
correctement une réinsertion sociale et
98% de ces condamnés sortant sorties
sèches c'est à dire sans aucune mesure
ni d'encadrement ni d'accompagnement ni
de contrainte et ces personnes la
plupart du temps lorsqu'elles sortent
des établissements pénitentiaires elles
sortent en rupture sociale plus forte
encore qu'à leurs entrées puisque 7 %
des personnes qui sont incarcérés sont
sans domicile fixe il sort de nos
établissements 14% qui sont sans
solution d'hébergement
il ya donc une rupture sociale aggravée
et je passe très vite sur les taux
d'addiction qui sont d'au moins 25% pour
une addiction et un peu plus encore pour
deux addictions et le taux d'illettrisme
qui est d'environ 27 18% dans nos
établissements bien supérieur à la
moyenne nationale
ce taux d'incarcération n'a cessé de
croître et aujourd'hui nous savons nous
sommes face à un taux de suroccupation
des maisons d'arrêt qui avoisine 140%
138,8 pensant exactement avec 1200
matelas à terre donc des conditions dont
on ne peut pas prétendre qu'elles soient
idéales pour préparer la sortie de façon
à ce que les détenus lorsqu'ils
reviennent dans la société ne soit pas
encore des dangers potentiels
enfin je parlais tout à l'heure en
termes de méthodes de la pression du
chiffre qui a été exercée sur les
services enquête elle a évidemment
contribué à engorger les tribunaux
elle a surtout saturer les services
d'hans tête et à consommer leurs
effectifs leurs moyens leur temps leur
énergie pourtant tellement nécessaires
au démantèlement des réseaux criminels
voilà sur la base de ces quelques
éléments les raisons pour lesquelles
nous avons estimé qu'il était utile de
concevoir une politique pénale
rationnelle fondée sur la connaissance
fondée sur l'évaluation de l'expérience
et qui affiche très clairement un
principe essentiel celui de l'efficacité
de la peine par un certain nombre de
deux modes de conception de la peine et
notamment l'individualisation de la
peine mais l'efficacité de la peine la
peine doit servir à punir mais
l'exécution de la peine doit préparer à
la réinsertion
c'est valable pour les longues peines
qui peut ni sur les crimes ça l'est
aussi pour les courtes peines qui
punissent les délits et je rappelle que
le texte sur lequel nous travaillons
nous concerne que les délits parce que
nous apportons des réponses efficaces à
ce qu'on appelle la petite délinquance
et j'y mets des guillemets parce que
c'est une petite délinquance en termes
de niveau de gravité des actes en termes
de gradation par rapport à la vitesse
l'échelle dès peines mais c'est une
petite délinquance qui peut avoir des
effets redoutables sur les victimes et
notamment sur les victimes les plus
vulnérables
nous avons eu le souci dans ce travail
méthodique et rigoureux de regarder
évidemment ce qui se faisait ailleurs
mais lorsque nous regardons ce qui se
fait ailleurs nous leur faisons avec
discernement c'est à dire que nous
estimons que ce qui se fait ailleurs ne
se transpose pas de façon mécanique ici
que ça doit être étudié dans la logique
de ce qui a été conçu et ailleurs en
tenant compte d'un certain nombre de
paramètres qui sont différents des
nôtres je pense évidemment aux codes
sociaux je pense aux références
historiques je pense aux codes culturels
je pense aux siens un certain nombre
d'éléments sociologique ou d'état
d'esprit collectif et en tout état de
cause ce qui est important et ce qui
d'ailleurs est efficace c'est de penser
les politiques publiques à partir de
l'histoire même du pays qui conçoit ses
politiques publiques et c'est pour ça
que nous avons interrogé l'histoire de
la france elle même parce que c'est
cette histoire qui est le terreau d'une
politique publique efficace parce
qu'elle est pensée par rapport à une
trajectoire par rapport à un certain
nombre de codes et de référence stable
et c'est bien pour cela qu'il apparaît
très clairement que dans l'histoire de
la france
la question de la réinsertion est une
question extrêmement importante qui a
plusieurs périodes de l'histoire s'est
ouvert au coeur de la pénalité
à plusieurs périodes de l'histoire parce
que les législateurs au fur et à mesure
qu'ils ont conçu un droit pénal et des
politiques pénales en cinq ans sur la
conception qu'ils avaient de l'utilité
et de l'efficacité de la peine et cette
tradition fait pénale qui s'est inscrite
et qui c'est qui c'est
enrichie dans le temps ses traditions
pénale elle nous vient en termes
d'inflexion forte de la révolution elle
nous vient de la révolution qui est du
code pénal de 1791 qui a aboli les
supplices la plupart d'entre eux mais
qui on a laissé quelques-uns qu'il a
fallu abolir après qui abolit les
supplices et elle nous vient aussi de la
philosophie des lumières qui pour la
première fois à penser la limitation de
la paix et en 1789 au moment de la
rédaction de la déclaration des droits
de l'homme et du citoyen adrienne du
port on est des rédacteurs disait qu'en
matière de peine
le minimum est ordonnée par l'humanité
est conseillé par la politique et que
toutes les fois où le but de la loi peut
être rempli par une peine c'est une
barbarie est un crime du législateur
dont employés une plus importante
une plus forte et il rejoint en cela le
principe qui a été posée par chez césar
et beccaria dans son traité des délits
et des peines ou il pose le principe
très clairement des peines strictement
nécessaire et cette conception de
l'utilité de l'efficacité de la peine
n'a cessé de s'enrichir de se développer
c'est une tradition humaniste de
l'histoire de la france c'est une
tradition qui a été républicaine n'est
pas exclusivement elle s'est développée
sur une barre au moment où la société se
devenait plus plus laïque mais elle a
été portée très fortement par la droite
chrétienne notamment et lorsque je
disais qu'elle n'était pas exclusivement
républicaine envoie des actes forts qui
sont posés sous la restauration
notamment à travers l'action et
l'affluence de la société royale pour
l'amélioration des prisons sous la
monarchie de juillet également à travers
tous ces débats sur le régime
pénitentiaire à travers l'action de
charles lucas qui était un inspecteur
général des prisons et catholique
sociale et qui a fortement oeuvré
notamment pour inspirer la loi de 1832
cette loi d'avril 1832 qui va abroger un
des supplices qui avait survécu au code
pénal de 1791 talent et l'amputation du
point en cas de parricide qui va
supprimer également l'âme art au fer
rouge des personnes qui sont condamnés
aux travaux forcés et qui va inciter les
juridictions par la loi à déroger aux
peines minimales qui sont contenues dans
le code au vu de la personnalité de
l'auteur de l'acte et des circonstances
de l'infraction
c'est de conception va se développer ici
dans cette maison au sénat notamment par
le travail conduit par le sénateur rené
bérenger qui avec le sénateur victor
schoelcher pour lequel vous savez que
j'ai une estime une affection
particulière
le sénateur rené bérenger qui siégeait
au centre de cet hémicycle et victor
schoelcher qui était républicain et
catholiques assumer affiché victor
schoelcher qui était athée insu mais est
affiché et qui était étonné d'ailleurs
de l'émoi qu'avait provoqué sa
déclaration ici même dans cet hémicycle
ils ont conduit ils ont animé ensemble
la commission d' enquête sénatoriale sur
la dette les conditions de détention et
le sénateur rené bérenger est à
l'origine vous le savez de la loi du 14
août 1885 qui crée la libération
conditionnelle et de la loi du 26 mars
1891 qui instaure le sursis simple cette
la gauche évidemment porte très
fortement cet héritage de ce que je
viens d'appeler d'humanisme pénale est
le porte et elle a été très très active
et très unis dans les années 1875 1885
pour protester contre les lois
d'exclusion et notamment les lois de
relégation des multi récidivistes dont
les bagnes coloniaux commencer par la
nouvelle calédonie et la guyane quelques
années après et clemenceau qui est une
figure emblématique à cette époque va
dire et va s'opposer évidemment à ces
textes de loi et il va déclarer que
toute pénalité qui n'aboutit pas à
l'amendement du coupable est une mesure
insuffisante de préservation sociale et
elle devient inutile dès lors que ce but
est atteint et c'est bien l'esprit qui a
inspiré
la conception de la contrainte sociale
qui doit s'adapter qui doit s'ajuster et
qui doit évaluer cet engagement de la
gauche sur l'utilité et l'efficacité de
la peine et la conception humaniste de
l'ascension qui doit être socialement
utiles et poursuivi évidemment par jean
jaurès notamment au début du 20e siècle
et en particulier en 1908 dans son
combat contre la peine de mort elle est
poursuivie aussi en 1945 après la
deuxième guerre mondiale avec les
actions et l'influente du conseil
national de la résistance qui va vous le
savez inspiré notamment l' ordonnance du
2 février 1945 sur l'enfance délinquante
cette ordonnance qui est porté par le
général de gaulle et qui on son exposé
des motifs indique que la france n'est
pas assez riche d'enfants pour avoir le
droit de négliger tous les moyens d'en
faire des et roussin et c'est à ces
périodes aussi que sera mise en place la
réforme pénitentiaire qu'on appelle la
réforme à mort et qui retient parmi ces
quatorze principe le premier qui
consiste à dire que la peine privative
de liberté a pour but essentiel
l'amendement et le reclassement social
du condamné
après nous avons évidemment pendant
toute cette période d'ailleurs la
défense sociale nouvelle chères au coeur
et à l'esprit de votre rapporteur qui a
créé et animé par marc en selle dans le
sillage des travaux et de la réflexion
de raymond saleh qui a conçu
l'individualisation de la peine et qui
va donner lieu à la création du sursis
avec mise à l'épreuve en 1958 ensuite il
ya les travaux et les initiatives de
robert badinter en tant que garde des
sceaux en
1982 avec la première loi avec la mise
en place la première loi de protection
des victimes d'infractions et la mise en
place d'un du premier bureau pour
accueillir les victimes de façon à ce
que elle commence à trouver une place
dans le procès pénal mais on a
évidemment surtout l'action de robert
badinter dans l'abolition de la peine de
mort et la création en 1983 duty c'est à
dire du travail d'intérêt général
elisabeth guigou le 15 juin 2000 en tout
cas par la loi du 15 juin 2000
renforçant la présomption d'innocence
elle renforce la protection des victimes
et elle crée le jeu des libertés et de
la détention
quant au sénat
quant au sénat il s'inscrit durablement
dans cette pratique dans cette tradition
humaniste dans cette conception utile
socialement de la peine
dans le temps je l' ai rappelé les
travaux de berranger de chair mais en a
eu d'autres mais récemment aussi de
façon contemporaine vous le savez
parfaitement les références sont
nombreuses je prendrai par exemple le
rapport de la commission denquête y est
cabanel qui date de 2000 et qui avec le
rapport du premier président de la cour
de cassation guy canivet a contribué
avec
le livre du dr besser avec le rapport de
l'assemblée nationale a contribué à
faire prendre conscience dans la société
de la nécessité de penser la peine de
penser le régime pénitentiaire à faire
en sorte que la société soit prête à
entendre que la prison doit être un
espace de droit et on se lasse et
travaux s'inscrivait dans une dynamique
qui était marqué notamment en 1995 par
une inversion de la jurisprudence du
conseil d'état qui a cessé à ce
moment-là de considérer que les
décisions de l'administration
pénitentiaire relevait simplement de
mesure d'ordre intérieur et a commencé à
construire une jurisprudence en
reconnaissant les droits fondamentaux
des détenus en reconnaissant les détenus
comme des sujets de droit et donc en
faisant en sorte que
l'aboutissement d'une certaine façon de
cela c'est en 2007 la création du
contrôleur général des lieux de
privation de liberté que vous avez votre
chambre à l'initiative du sénat a
enrichi à renforcer avant le départ de
monsieur delarue sur la base d'une
proposition de loi de madame la ministre
et catherine tasca et bien entendu
l'aboutissement c'est la loi
pénitentiaire de 2009 et cette loi
pénitentiaire de 2009 a été fortement
enrichi par le sénat pas c'est aux
chambres c'est ce que vous confirmez
n'est ce pas monsieur le président y est
absolument elle a été fortement enrichi
le rapporteur on était jean rené lecerf
qui a enrichi très très fortement à
consolider et à renforcer ce texte et
qui à l'époque déclarait qu' en matière
correctionnelle
les perles les peines d'emprisonnement
doivent constituer l'ultime recours et
l'exécution de la peine doit être
orienté vers la réinsertion de la
personne détenue et vous monsieur le
président de la commission des lois de
l'époque monsieur jean jacques hyest
vous avez fortement à prouver puisque
vous avez notamment déclaré que les
courtes peines sont génératrices plus
souvent de récidive que d'exemplarité et
il faut penser à d'autres solutions que
la détention et ce texte de loi de très
grande qualité
ce texte de loi de très grande qualité a
été votée à l'unanimité c'est à dire que
tous les groupes du sénat entend richy
et ont apporté leur sensibilité dans ce
texte donc lorsque je parle de ces
traditions pénale humaniste qui
s'inscrit dans la durée je parle de
votre tradition bien entendu je parle de
notre tradition celle qui avec constance
veille à l'avancé des sociétés humaines
pourquoi parce que elle cette conception
est tourné vers le rétablissement du
lien social à un moment où ce lien
social se déchirent de toutes parts elle
est tournée vers le respect de la
dignité que c'est dignité occupe une
place centrale dans la modernité la
dignité des victimes que nous devons
respecter accompagner et pour laquelle
nous devons mener des actes de
réparation et que nous n'avons pas le
droit de réduire à des espèces de boules
de vengeance la dignité du condamné
parce qu'il faut qu'ils puissent
réintégrer le corps social et
le condamné ne peut pas être réduit lui
non plus peut pas être rétrécie à l'acte
qu'il a commis et encore moins à la à ce
qu'ils pourraient commettre la dignité
on oublie souvent aussi des personnels
pénitentiaires qui doivent pouvoir
exercer leurs missions dans des
conditions qui ne soient pas un dessin
comme trop souvent elles le sont qu'ils
ne soient pas absurde comme trop souvent
elles le sont enfin la peine est tourné
vers l'avenir et c'est la condition de
son efficacité c'est donc dans cette
logique que nous avons conçu ce texte de
loi ce texte de loi qui je le disais
pose le principe de l'individualisation
de la peine nous avons écrit un nouvel
article nous avons introduit un nouvel
article dans le code pénal et ce nouvel
article énonce les finalités les
fonctions de la peine
sanctionné et favoriser l'amendement
l'insertion et la réinsertion en
commission des lois votre rapporteur a
indiqué qu'il avait il éprouvait un
relatif malaise à l'égard du terme
amendement parce que ils suspectent un
peu je traduis peut-être sa pensée il
suspecte ce terme de ne pas appartenir
totalement la sémantique séculière
je rappelle simplement que ce terme fait
partie de cette tradition que je viens
de tracer et il rappelle simplement il
indique simplement que le condamné le
coupable l'auteur de l'acte doit prendre
conscience de sa responsabilité
vis-à-vis de lui-même vis-à-vis d'autrui
à qu'il aurait infligé un préjudice et
vis-à-vis de la société et cette prise
de conscience est indispensable pour
garantir les conditions de réinsertion
durable la peine est prononcée donc avec
sa dimension rétribue t-il sa dimension
afflictive c'est à dire que l est la
stigmatisation de l'acte est posée
stigmatisation par rapport aux principes
par rapport aux valeurs par rapport aux
règles de la société qui sont pour
reprendre encore une expression de
durkheim les états forts de la
conscience collective et la sanction
affermi justement ces états forts de la
conscience collective
donc cela et pose les choses sont posés
ainsi pour la tenue même mais nous
l'avons la peine doit aussi favoriser
l'amendement l'insertion et la
réinsertion pour cela c'est la personne
qui est prise en compte et elle est
prise en compte dans sa responsabilité
parce que l'individualisation n'annule
pas la responsabilité de l'individu au
contraire et selon les travaux de la
défense sociale nouvelles et de
saleilles c'est justement cette
responsabilisation qui constituent le
moteur de l'art socialisation donc elle
n'est pas écartée elle est prise en
compte simplement la peine doit être
prononcée par rapport à l'individualité
au parcours aux circonstances
nous avons donc dans ce texte décidé de
supprimer les automatismes qui limitait
le pouvoir d'appréciation du juge de
façon à lui permettre de prononcer la
peine la plus adaptée nous avons
constaté les statistiques l'établissent
que les peines planchers les premiers
automatismes les peines plancher ont
concerné essentiellement ce qu'on
appelle des petits délits avec des
guillemets 47% de vol et d'atteintes aux
biens c'est à dire qu'elles ont changé
les pratiques des juridictions au sens
où les juridictions ont prononcé des
peines plus sévères pour
les délits punissables de
moins ou de trois ans pour des peines
donc houleux la peine pour des fêtes où
la peine encourue est inférieure ou
égale à trois ans et avant ce texte avec
les automatismes de la peine plancher
ces peines minimales équivalent puisque
les juridictions sont en fait c'est vert
était prononcée dans 14% des cas à
partir de la loi a été prononcée dans 44
% des cas pour quel résultat
une plus grande sévérité pour quel
résultat
monsieur détraigne lors des débats sur
la loi pénitentiaire
vous êtes posé cette question et vous
même vous avez déclaré que si la
fonction de la peine consiste notamment
à être efficaces et dissuasives
je ne suis pas certain que l'aggravation
et la systématisation des peines
d'emprisonnement
soit la meilleure manière de lutter
contre la récidive
et les statistiques vous donne raison
les statistiques vous donne raison parce
que au thème du perm d'incarcération le
risque de récidive est deux fois plus
élevé qu'au terme d'une sursis avec mise
à l'épreuve et je rappelle que notre
code pénal est déjà sévère il contient
des circonstances aggravantes qui
aboutissent à des lois à des peines très
lourdes et dans le code pénal de 1791
déjà se trouve et jusqu'à aujourd'hui le
la condition de récidive avec un
doublement de la peine encourue nous
avons donc décidé de supprimer les
automatismes les peines planchers de
supprimer la révocation automatique de
des sursis mais bien entendu la
juridiction pourra décider de la
révocation des sursis si elle juge utile
nous avons introduit également la
possibilité de la césure du procès pénal
qui permet à la juridiction en deux
temps d'une part de déclarer rapidement
la culpabilité et de prononcer les
mesures d'indemnisation de la victime ou
des victimes s'il y en a ensuite dans un
deuxième temps à partir d'éléments
denquête recueillies sur l'auteur de
décider de l'ascension c'est une option
évidemment ça n'est pas une obligation
nous créons la contrainte pénale qui est
une peine en milieu ouvert qui est une
peine autonome déconnecté de la prison
ce qui la change de du sursis avec mise
à l'épreuve qui est directement une
peine de prison qui est par la suite
aménager partiellement haute ou
totalement et qui cette conception
différente permet de rendre
symboliquement avec l'idée que la prison
l'incarcération est la seule réponse
possible est la seule mesure possible du
d'un acte délictueux cette contrainte
pénal diffère du fme mais nous y
reviendrons dans la discussion des
articles elle diffère du fme parce
qu'une évaluation obligatoire préalable
a lieu elle commence dès le prononcé de
la sanction puisque cette contrainte
pénale est exécutoire par provision et
le juge d'application des peines peut
prononcer des obligations et des
interdictions plus large que celle du
sms ça aussi c'est une distinction le
contrôle est effectué par un programme
de responsabilisation qui permet de
prononcer une peine ajusté qui s'adapte
qui s'évalue obligatoirement c'est prévu
par la loi nous introduisons des
dispositions qui permettent aux forces
de sécurité la police et la gendarmerie
de participer au contrôle sous forme de
retenue ou de visites domiciliaires et
nous enrichissons le fichier de des
personnes recherchées des obligations
importantes qui permettant de procéder à
ce contrôle évidemment s'il ya un échec
total et qu'il est constaté cela
conduira à une incarcération
mais cette contrainte pénale est appelé
à être prononcé dans des cas où
aujourd'hui on a un sursis avec mise à
l'épreuve mais où la personnalité de
l'auteur fait que suivi s'avère
nécessaire ou dans des cas où des
courtes peines d'emprisonnement sont
prononcés actuellement du fait de la loi
pénitentiaire
lorsqu'il n'ya pas un mandat de dépôt
ces peines doivent être aménagés et ne
sont donc pas exécutoire immédiatement
votre rapporteur a introduit une
disposition nouvelle concernant la
contrainte pénale nous y reviendrons
comme je les ai dit en commission des
lois la philosophie n'est pas la même la
nôtre n'était pas référencé au à des
types d'infractions elle était plutôt
référence et à la personnalité qui
nécessiteraient un suivi plus ajustée
mais je pense que nous aurons ce débat
tout à l'heure par ailleurs puisque les
études et les statistiques ont prouvé
que la récidive les risques de récidive
sont plus élevés en lorsqu'il y à une
sortie sèche que lorsqu'il ya une
condition une libération conditionnelle
nous avons introduit la libération sous
contrainte qui permet que aux deux tiers
de l'exécution de la peine rendez vous
judiciaire obligatoire permet à la
commission d'application des peines de
décider éventuellement d'une libération
sous contrainte sous forme de placement
extérieur de bracelet électronique ou de
libé de semi-liberté de libération
conditionnelle
évidemment cette commission peut décider
le maintien en détention voyage voilà
les principales dispositions de ce texte
de loi dont nous allons débattre tout à
l'heure évidemment je sais que vous avez
la préoccupation parce que vous l'avez
dit à plusieurs reprises des moyens qui
vont accompagner ces dispositions
normatives ne gouvernement s'est donné
les moyens d'abord les moyens de
l'encadrement pour la réinsertion avec
une augmentation de 25% du corps du
corps des conseillers d'insertion et de
probation 25% en trois ans puisque un
millier de recrutements auront lieu 400
ont déjà eu lieu cette année 2014
63 avait déjà eu lieu l'année dernière
et malgré le contexte budgétaire
contraint nous avons créé l'an dernier
63 postes de speed je viens de le dire
mais également 49 postes de magistrats
d'application des peines ainsi que des
postes de greffiers ce que nous faisons
encore cette année
nous avons monsieur lecerf vous aviez
d'ailleurs fait observer lors de votre
dans votre rapport sur l'évaluation de
l'application de la loi pénitentiaire
vous aviez faire observer que pour l'
axe d'aménagement des peines le
renforcement du corps des conseillers
d'insertion et de probation et est
important c'est évidemment ce que nous
faisons avec ce texte de loi par
ailleurs nous avons pris un certain de
dispositions que j'aurai l'occasion
puisque j'ai bien conscience d'avoir
abusé de votre attention ce soir que
j'aurai l'occasion de développer très
probablement après la présentation de la
motion de procédure le syndic ray en
termes de politiques publiques en termes
de moyens en terme de politique
vis-à-vis des victimes toutes les
dispositions que nous avons prises dans
ce texte de loi est tout ce que nous
avons déjà mis en place depuis deux ans
dans ce texte de loi nous introduisant
la justice restaurative nous avons
réécrit l'article 7 100 cède qui
rassemble les droits des victimes parce
que ses droits et paix part dans l'auto
code de procédure pénale nous les
rassemblant nous les renforts sont et
nous faisons en sorte que la victime ait
droit à la sûreté et la sécurité dans le
processus d'exécution de la peine nous
avons créé avec l'assemblée nationale
des contributions pour l'aide aux
victimes dans ce texte et vous savez que
nous travaillons sur les procédures
mesdames et messieurs voilà l'essentiel
du texte je le répète j'aurai l'occasion
de répondre à vos interrogations et aux
inquiétudes sur les politiques publiques
et les moyens que nous mettons pour le
succès de ce texte il s'agit d'un texte
de raison un texte de raisons telles que
l'entendait les philosophes des lumières
un texte de raisons telles que
l'entendait aussi bertold brecht lorsque
dans ce qu'il a écrit sur la vie de
galilée il disait que cette vieille qui
la veille d'un voyage de sa mère rude
donne une double touffe de foin aux
mulets que ce capitaine de navire qui
pour l'achat des vivres pense aussi bien
à la tempête qu'a l'accalmie que cet
enfant qui enfonce bonnet dans sa tête
parce qu'on l'a convaincu qui peut
pleuvoir tout cela sont mon espérance
parce que tous il se laisse convaincre
par des raisons et brecht ajouté oui je
crois à la douce violence de la raison à
la longue personne ne peut lui résister
merci
merci madame la ministre la parole est à
monsieur jean pierre michel rapporteur
de la commission des lois
ce président madame la ministre mes
chers collègues
après cet exposé magistral de l'histoire
du droit pénal da prison
matinée de sociologie et de philosophie
nous allons à venir à des propos plus
triviaux une excuse mais le rapporteur
de la commission des lois doit bien vous
exposer le texte tel qu'il est et tel
que la commission a souhaité qu'il
devienne
alors ce projet de loi a été adopté par
l'assemblée nationale vous le savez qui
a ajouté un nombre d'articles et il en
comprend aujourd'hui 51
comme l'a dit madame l'ami tout à
l'heure il fait suite aux travaux de la
conférence de consensus je dirais
simplement que c'est la première fois en
matière judiciaire qu'on fait précéder
un projet de loi d'une consultation
aussi large ofi diversifié aussi
différente dans les acteurs de cette
consultation
comme ça s'est fait dans d'autres
domaines d'ailleurs pour arriver à un
projet de loi qui est pensé et qui n'est
pas l'objet de
la réponse à un fait divers quelconque
quelques dramatique qu'il fut donc dans
ses objectifs ce projet de loi vise à
remettre le principe d'individualisation
de la peine
au coeur de la mission du juge
quoi qu'on puisse dire certains
magistrats est dans la continuité de la
loi pénitentiaire
il affirme que la sanction pénale doit
permettre avant tout la réinsertion du
délinquant je préfère dire ça re
socialisation afin d'éviter la récidive
dans ses modalités fait un texte prudent
qui ne va pas aussi loin que certains
auraient souhaité notamment que le jury
de consensus aurait souhaité mais qui
peut être compte tenu de l'état de
l'opinion publique sur ces sujets et de
la contre information qui est faite sur
ces sujets là aussi faut bien le dire
par un certain nombre de médias
particulièrement mal intentionnés il me
paraît équilibré et donc je vous
proposerai de l'adopter dans la version
qui a été établi par votre commission
des lois mais avant d'aborder le contenu
du texte je voudrais faire un bref
rappel de contexte généralement un effet
nous sommes actuellement dans une
période d'inflation pénale et
d'habitation carcéral malgré la
diversification des sanctions pénales la
prison reste la peine de référence pour
les magistrats et avec plus de 68 milles
648 personnes détenus au 1er mai au 1er
juin 2014 nous avons renoué avec les
taux d'incarcération de la fin du 19e
siècle c'est à croire que tout ce qui a
été fait depuis n'a pas servi à grand
chose en valeur absolue nous nous
situons dans une position médiane par
rapport à nos voisins européens
mais à la différence de l'allemagne des
pays-bas du royaume-uni où le taux
d'incarcération diminue le nombre
d'études en france continue à augmenter
rapidement et constamment + 8 % entre
2009 et 2014 et aujourd'hui le taux de
détention et 205 pour 1000 à 10000
habitants
se tient principalement à deux facteurs
à mon avis d'une part à l'augmentation
de la durée des peines prononcées en
lien notamment avec des peines planchers
et d'autre part à l'augmentation des
nombres d'entrées en détention en
particulier des courtes peines or on le
sait
les établissements pénitentiaires ne
sont pas en mesure d'accueillir
l'ensemble des détenus un quart des
prisons françaises présentent un taux
d'occupation supérieur à 150 % et
environ 1200 détenus dorment
d'actuellement sur des matelas posés par
terre dans les airs
cette situation de surpopulation
carcérale pose de nombreuses difficultés
promiscuité
violences agressions envers les
personnels pénitentiaires et ne permet
pas à l'administration pénitentiaire de
mettre en oeuvre des projets de
réinsertion qui tienne la route à cet
égard d'ailleurs le bilan de
l'application de la pénitentiaire est
encore décevant comme l'avait souligné
dans le rapport il y a deux ans
jean rené lecerf qui avait été le
rapporteur du texte et notre collègue
nicole borvo qui depuis a quitté notre
assemblée
s'agissant par exemple d'une obligation
d'activité celle ci représente environ
quatre heures entre 4h30 d'activités
offertes en moyenne par semaine aux
détenus et pour l'essentiel il s'agit de
sport ou de la fréquentation de la
bibliothèque
par ailleurs les aménagements de peines
ont effectivement beaucoup augmenté
comme le souhaitait la pénitentiaire
mais surtout au bénéfice du placement
sous surveillance électronique qui se
conclue pour l'essentiel à vérifier que
le condamné se trouve à son domicile
hauteur fixée par le juge actuellement
onze mille 48 détenus sont dans cette
situation
al'inverse les mesure de semi-liberté de
placement à l'extérieur qui permet de
travailler la réinsertion sont très peu
développé dans ces conditions les
sorties sèches demeurent majoritaires
80% détenus sortent sans avoir fait
l'objet du moindre accompagnement mais
cette proportion monte à 84% pour les
condamner à une peine entre six mois et
un an et même à 98 % pour les condamnés
à moins de six mois or on le sait ces
sorties sèches augmente le risque de
récidive à la sortie les condamnés se
réinsère de lahoud là où ils viennent
c'est à dire dans le milieu de la
délinquance dont ils sont sortis pour
entrer en prison c'est une des raisons
d'ailleurs pour lesquels un certain
nombre de nos voisins européens et ne
parle pas de pays exotiques comme le
canada ou les pays nordiques se pare de
l'allemagne par exemple ou de la suisse
faut savoir que nous les droites
allemand contient une disposition
spécifique qui concerne les courtes
peines
et qui limite la possibilité pour le
juge de prononcer des peines inférieures
à six mois d'emprisonnement lorsqu'il le
fait il doit motiver sa décision
spécifiquement par rapport à la gravité
de l'infraction ou à la personnalité de
l'auteur quant à la suisse elle a
interdit carrément le prononcé de ses
peines à moins de six mois
d'emprisonnement donc je dirais qu'à
côté de ça la peine de concret au pénal
est vraiment très très timorés
dans ces conditions
donc cette situation elle a été aussi on
peut dire qu'elle n'a pas été amélioré
par les lois sur la récidive qui ont été
adoptées entre 2005 et 2012 vous
trouverez dans le rapport écrit une
présentation de l'ensemble des mesures
adoptées dans la plus emblématique
concerne l'instauration des peines
planchers il ya eu aussi une restriction
des conditions d'accès aux aménagements
de peine une surveillance plus facile à
la fin de la peine et des dispositions
sur les mineurs pour écarter l'excusé de
minorité et instaurer les tribunaux
correctionnels pour mineurs à la place
des tribunaux pour enfants à l'apparence
d'ailleurs c'est loi repose sur une
logique qui peut se comprendre et qui
peut se défendre
c'est la gradation de la réponse
judiciaire face à quelqu'un qui s'entête
dans la délinquance or le malheur c'est
que en réalité ces réponses ne sont pas
pertinentes et
je dirais que tout le montre d'abord
parce que la notion de récidive légale
est une notion complexe
à laquelle le grand public ne comprend
rien qui se distingue de concours
d'infractions qui se distingue des
réintégrations d'infraction et donc qui
ne reflète pas ce que les gens appellent
avait habituellement récidive
d'autre part parce que cette logique de
gradation de la réponse pénale n'est pas
toujours adaptée aux situations
concrètes et aux différentes
trajectoires de sortie de délinquance on
pense on parle à ce sujet de désiste ans
qui sont loin d'être rectiligne
sur ces sujets
la règle classique doublement des peines
encourues en cas de récidive permet déjà
au juge d'ailleurs d'adapter le
comptable de l'ascension en cas d'espèce
comme le faisait remarquer au cours
d'une de nos séances de commission
madame catherine tasca je dirais enfin
un mot des peines exécutées en milieu
ouvert il ya un paradoxe qui étaient
relevés par la cour des comptes en 2010
les peines de milieux ouverts sont
quantitativement importante mais
qualitativement négliger la cour des
comptes je veux notamment parlé du
socialiser les preuves qui représente
les trois quarts des mesures suivies en
milieu ouvert
près de 80000 prononcé en 2011 dont un
tiers dans le cas d'une peine mixte ou
encore du titre 15 mille peines
prononcées en 2011 en revanche les
peines alternatives comme les stages
hiver les annulations de permis sont
beaucoup moins prononcé ces peines sont
pourtant intéressantes car elles
permettent un suivi et elles permettent
d'éviter les effets désocialisant d'une
incarcération mais leurs conditions
d'exécution pose des problèmes nous
savons bien des problèmes de moyens cher
monsieur détraigne sur le sursis mise à
l'épreuve d'ailleurs les contraintes
imposées à la personne ne sont pas
toujours bien adapté les délais
d'exécution sont souvent longs et bien
souvent la prise en charge par les
services de probation se résume à un
simple contrôle du respect des
obligations sans suivi particulier axé
sur la réinsertion et la prévention de
la récidive
nous avons déjà souvent parle également
des difficultés rencontrées pour
multiplié les offres de tiges auprès des
collectivités locales et des organismes
publics notamment ces difficultés sont
notamment imputables à la crise
d'identité que traversent les services
de probation en milieu ouvert d'ailleurs
j'en retiens servent en a parlé dans son
avis budgétaire il ya quelques mois à
l'heure actuelle les services de
probation en milieu ouvert sans saturer
en théorie chaque conseiller s'occupe
d'environ 90 mesure mais en réalité ce
ratio atteint souvent 150 à 200 mesures
par conseiller
ce qui est totalement anormal et par
comparaison un opérateur un éducateurs
de la pjj il suit en moyenne 25 mineurs
les services de probation sont
d'ailleurs confrontés à une crise
d'identité avec le recentrage de leur
mission sur la prévention de la récidive
qui a laissé de côté le travail social
et la loi du 27 mars 2012 à laquelle
nous étions opposés leur a retiré une
grande partie des enquêtes de
personnalité présentenciel c'est dans
ces conditions que les personnels des
services de probation vont faire l'objet
d'un renouvellement de génération dans
les années à venir avec l'annoncé par le
gouvernement du recrutement de 1000
personnels supplémentaires d'ici à 2017
soit une augmentation du corps lors de
25% pour permettre l'application du
présent projet de loi 400 postes ont
d'ores et déjà été ouverts par le vote
finances pour 2014 et l'objectif énoncé
par le premier ministre jean-marc
ayrault mais le gouvernement actuel suit
le précédent sur ce point là mon cher
collègue lors du dépôt de ce projet de
loi était de parvenir à terme à un ratio
de 40 mesures par conseillers de
probation
j'en viens maintenant après une
introduction peut-être un peu longue à
ce projet de loi qui a été
significativement enrichi comme on dit
par les travaux de l'assemblée nationale
je reviens très rapidement sur le projet
de loi initial du gouvernement il
contient notamment un important volet
consacré à l'individuation des peines
avec la suppression des peines planchers
le rétablissement de l'obligation de
motivation de toute peine
d'emprisonnement ferme non aménagés y
compris pour les récidivistes et la
révocation du sursis qui ne sera plus
automatique par ailleurs le projet de
loi crée une nouvelle procédure de
césure du procès pénal pour permettre de
faire des investigations sur la
personnalité sur le modèle de ce qui
existe déjà pour les mineurs
le projet de loi propose par ailleurs de
développer l'approbation en s'inspirant
des expériences conduites dans les pays
anglo-saxons et sur les recommandations
du conseil de l'europe il crée notamment
cette nouvelle peine dite de contrainte
pénale peut-être qu'on aurait pu trouver
un autre nom mais c'est celui là qui
restent
car c'est une contrainte elle et pénales
donc c'est une tautologie total
susceptible d'être prononcée pour des
infractions punies de cinq ans
d'emprisonnement maximum lorsque la
personnalité de l'auteur justifie un
accompagnement socio éducatif renforcé
cette peine pourrait être prononcée pour
une durée de six mois à cinq ans ce qui
est très long et comprendrait des
mesures d'assistance de contrôle de
suivi ainsi que certaines obligations
interdiction exécution d'un stage d'un
tiges
réparation d'un dommage que la victime
est l'enfant de soins etc sa mise en
oeuvre posera avant tout sur les juges
d'application des peines et sur les
conseillers d'insertion et de probation
une arrivée une réévaluation régulière
de la situation de la personne seront
mis sera mise en place
par ailleurs afin de limiter les sorties
sèches le projet de loi crée une
procédure de libération sous contrainte
qui obligera l'administration
pénitentiaire a examiné la situation de
toutes les personnes condamnées à une
peine inférieure ou égale à cinq ans
lorsqu'elles ont exécuté les deux tiers
de leur peine afin de décider si
possible une mesure de sorties encadrées
en inverse sans que l'on comprenne
parfaitement la cohérence d'ensemble du
projet son article 7 revient sur une des
mesures essentielles de la loi
pénitentiaire du 24 novembre 2009 en
ramenant de deux ans à un an pour les
non récidivistes et d'un an à six mois
pour les récidivistes
le seuil d'emprisonnement permettant un
ami un aménagement de peine à benicio
par ailleurs le projet de loi met
l'accent sur la nécessité d'éviter les
ruptures de prise en charge entre les
milieux fermés et le milieu ouvert à nos
associés en plus étroitement les
services publics concernés et enfin il
reconnaît expressément les droits des
victimes tout au long de l'exécution des
peines il renforce également les
pouvoirs de police et de gendarmerie en
matière de contrôle et de respect pour
une personne condamnée des obligations
résultant de sa condamnation
alors les députés on peut modifier des
articles du projet initial ils ont en
revanche procéder à de nombreux ajouts
et il faut souligner la qualité du
travail du rapporteur à l'assemblée
nationale dominique raimbourg
sur ces articles je mens seigneuret
trois sujets d'une part sur les
aménagements de peine nos collègues
députés ont prévu un compte unique d'un
an d'emprisonnement applicable aux
récidivistes comme aux récidivistes
d'autre part sur le champ de la
contrainte pénale ils sont parvenus à un
compromis avec le gouvernement en
prévoyant que la contrainte pénal cp
carreaux délit puni de cinq ans jusqu'en
jamais 2017 et à compter de cette date à
tous les délits si je dis cela c'est que
après j'ai proposé des modifications
enfin ils ont prévu que les forces de
police et de gendarmerie pourrait
recourir à la géolocalisation à
l'interception des communications
lorsqu ils soupçonnent qu'une personne
ne respecte pas les obligations
résultant de sa condamnation
nos collègues députés ont par ailleurs
enrichi de textes de 30 articles
nouveaux notamment puis une exposition
sur les victimes
la consécration des bureaux des deux
victimes la possibilité de recourir à un
justice restaurative avec l'accord de la
victime une nouvelle procédure
d'indemnisation lorsque la victime ne
s'est pas constituée partie civile et la
création d'une sorte on y reviendra tout
à l'heure de taxe de 10% sur toutes les
amendes pénales prononcées afin de
financer le fonds d'aidé aux victimes
sur l'exécution des peines ils ont
notamment prévu que lorsqu'on condamne
et n'aura pas pu voulu bénéficier ou pas
voulu bouleverser bénéficier de
l'aménagement de peine il pourrait être
soumis par le pendant la durée des
crédits de peine et des réductions
supplémentaires de peine au respect de
certaines mesures de contrôle
obligations ou interdictions pour
permettre sa réinsertion d'autre part
ils ont intégré la proposition de loi de
notre collègue hélène lipietz qui n'est
plus parmi nous aujourd'hui qui avait
été votée ici à l'unanimité je crois sur
la suspension de l'extension provisoire
pour motif médical que les avions voté
en février dernier ils ont allégé la
procédure de suspension de peine pour
raison médicale
enfin ils ont ajouté un volet prévention
de la délinquance en prévoyant plusieurs
mesures pour impliquer davantage les
acteurs locaux de terrain comme cela se
pratique dans les pays anglo-saxons et
au canada notamment au sein des comités
locaux de prévention de la délinquance
plus problématique enfin ils ont adopté
plusieurs articles qui augmente
considérablement les pouvoirs de la
police et de la gendarmerie j'y
reviendrai tout à l'heure quand je pense
quand je pense que ces articles auxquels
le ministère de l'intérieur est
d'ailleurs opposé pose un problème de
constitutionnalité
j'en viens à présent à la poésie à la
position que votre commission des lois a
adopté et que je vous propose également
de suivre
en ce qui concerne votre rapporteur et
la commission ce projet de loi se situe
comme je l'aï dit tout à l'heure dans la
continuité de la loi pénitentiaire il
insiste sur des principes qui ont été
rappelés tout à l'heure par madame la
garde des sceaux que l'autre commission
a toujours défendu y compris ceux la
précédente majorité
intervalles irréguliers
peut-être à savoir la nécessité de prise
de préparer leur insertion de la
personne condamnée et la liberté
d'appréciation laissée aux juges en cela
il se situe dans la lignée de ce qu'on a
dit c'est à dire l'école de défense
sociale qui au sortir de la guerre de 45
par des hommes qui avaient vécu la
déportation et les camps de
concentration ont voulu affirmer leur
foi en la réinsertion et à la
possibilité la recentralisation de tous
les délinquants et même de tous les
criminels
ceci a et a eu deux je dirais à une
culture d'exception d'une part la
néfaste loi sécurité et liberté et les
différentes lois sur la récidive mais
pour le reste pour le reste nos lois se
sont situées dans cette continuité
d'humanisme et d'écoles de défense
sociale très inspiré par le
christianisme social
votre commission de l'oeuvre repose donc
sur la contrainte pénal sur la
contrainte pénale nous approuvons
totalement la création qui devait
permettre de combler un peu le retard de
notre pays en matière de probation mais
j'ai proposé plusieurs amendes
ajustements qui ont été acceptées par
votre commission d'abord sur le champ de
la contrainte pénale gens pètent
d'accord avec le compromis trouvé
l'assemblée nationale consistant à
procéder par étapes d'abord pour des
livres 5 ans tous les délits plus tard
peut-être après une évaluation en 2017
le système voté par les députés présente
un défaut il continue de faire de la
contrainte pénal une simple alternative
à l'emprisonnement le jus pouvant
prononcé l'une ou l'autre de ses peines
dans ces conditions je crains que les
magistrats la prononce peu il faut
sortir de l'idée que la prison est la
seule peine adaptée pour tous types
d'infractions et notamment pour les
petits délits et afin de faire évoluer
notre système pénal la commission vous
propose un amendement qui en plus de ce
café l'assemblée nationale fait de la
contrainte pénal d'une peine de
référence unique avait bien entendu les
peines alternatives et les sanctions
pécuniaires pour un certain nombre de
délits plus graves la liste qui a été
retenu est exclu bennett toutes les
atteintes aux personnes il s'agit du vol
simple de la conduite sous l'empiré d'un
état alcoolique et cetera cela ne
signifie pas d'ailleurs que la
contrainte pénale devrait prononcer dans
tous les cas pour cette infraction c'est
le juge considère que la contrainte
pénale est une sanction trop lourde mais
il pourra toujours avoir recours à une
peine d'amendé intime un stage 1 et
addictions permis de conduire à la
confiscation d'un véhicule et cetera et
cetera mais il ne pourra plus prononcer
de peines de prison
c'est à cela qu'il faut aboutir et nous
verrons d'ici quelques années s'il est
opportun d'élargir ce système comme je
le souhaite pour moi à terme il faudra
passer en matière correctionnelle du
diptyque prison amende au triptyque
prison contraintes pénale amende si ce
n'est être été proposées tout au long
des auditions que nous avons menées et
par robert badinter est pas la
commission consultative droits de
l'homme et par madalim delmas parti et
par
madame herzog evans et par monsieur
serpents etc etc j'en passe et des
meilleurs je vous proposerai également
de simplifier le système voté par les
députés en faisant de la sanction de non
respect des obligations de la contrainte
pénal un délit autonome
puis d'une peine de deux ans
d'emprisonnement c'est ce qui c'est ce
qui existe déjà pour les tiges car je
pense que le système du projet de loi
à quelques difficultés constitutionnel
d'autre part je vous proposera également
plusieurs ajustements qui vise notamment
à rééquilibrer les pouvoirs entre la
juridiction de jugement et le japon se
considère pour ma part que le japon
n'est pas le juge qui prononce la
sanction
c'est le juge qui prononce les
obligations qui sont à l'intérieur de
cette sanction et qui vérifient leur
exécution
c'est les aménagements de peine je vous
proposerai d'en revenir au droit issu de
loi pénitentiaire c'est à dire un seuil
de 2 ans d'emprisonnement et un an pour
les récidivistes et en cela je suis ce
que le gouvernement prétendez vouloir
c'est à dire faire une différence entre
les récidivistes et les non récidivistes
en effet l'abaissement du coin comme
proposé par le projet de loi est non
seulement un cohérent avec le reste du
projet mais il devrait en outre conduire
augmenter mécaniquement de 5000 le
nombre de peines non aménageables ce qui
n'est à mon avis pas envisageable dans
la situation actuelle de l'établissement
pénitentiaire nous avons souvent insisté
ici pour préserver un équilibre qui me
paraît bon et je me repose sur ce point
de rester fidèle à la position de notre
commission tel qu'il s'était exprimé au
moment du vote de la loi pénitentiaire
enfin votre commission vous propose de
supprimer un certain nombre d'articles
introduit par les députés qui vise à
donner de nouveaux pouvoirs à la police
et la gendarmerie sans aucun contrôle il
faut bien le dire possibilité de
recourir à la géolocalisation de
l'interception de communications à
l'encontre toute personne sortant de
détention sans que la finalité en soi
expliqué possibilité donnée aux op j de
mettre en oeuvre une transaction pénale
qui est contraire à la séparation des
pouvoirs à mon avis ou des alternatives
aux poursuites d'office possibilité de
communiquer des documents couverts par
le secret de l'en-tête de l'instruction
notamment aux comités locaux de
prévention de la délinquance
donc au préfet et au maire le ministère
de l'intérieur d'ailleurs à confirmer
lors des auditions qu'ils étaient des
femmes leur à la fois dispositions qui
posent de nombreuses difficultés et qui
passerait difficilement mon avis en tel
quel
l'épreuve du conseil constitutionnel
enfin sur la création d'une taxe de 10%
sur toutes les amendes pénales et les
sanctions financières
pour aider les financer l'aide aux
victimes bien entendu que je sais que la
commission et moi même je suis favorable
dans le principe à sa disposition mais
il y a peut être un risque car il faut
préciser la nature juridique cette
majoration qui n'est pas claire
s'agissait d'une taxe s'agit que d'une
sanction et en toute hypothèse pour ne
pas risquer la contestation sur le
fondement du principe de
proportionnalité
je vous proposerai d'instaurer un
plafond mais depuis le gouvernement a
proposé une nouvelle rédaction de cet
article qui vous ressemble à quai auquel
vraisemblablement demain matin en
commission jeunes reines avis favorable
enfin je terminerai en vous proposant
trois ajouts au texte
d'une part la suppression des tribunaux
correctionnels pour mineurs comme le
propose également madame benbassa et
mesdames clairement deux amendements
semblables ces juridictions ne rien
apporter elle ne prononce pas des
sanctions plus sévères pour les
tribunaux pour enfants elles ont
compliqué le travail des juridictions
tout en écartant la société civile
puisque les assesseurs devant lequel
nous pourrons enfin hollande était exclu
tous les magistrats sans exception qui
m'ont parlé de ce texte soit à
l'occasion de ce débat soit à l'occasion
du rapport que j'ai fait sur la pjj au
cours du dernier sommet de l'année
dernière sont prononcés pour la
suppression de ces tribunaux
correctionnels pour mineurs d'autre part
sur la rétention de sûreté
je vous proposerai un dispositif
intermédiaire est assez subtile car des
personnes fait actuellement l'objet
d'une surveillance de sûreté et il ne
serait pas responsable de supprimer
totalement cette mesure sans prévoir de
suivi pour ces personnes
l'amendement que vous proposez que la
commission a adopté supprime la
rétention de sûreté en tant que tel mais
concerne la surveillance de sûreté et
créé un délit autonome pour le cas où
une personne ne respecterait pas ses
obligations
enfin nous avons souvent parlé de la
situation des malades mentaux en prison
dans notre commission et je vous
proposerai d'intégrer le dispositif de
la proposition de loi de jean rené
lecerf dont il était le rapporteur que
le sénat avait voté le nid mitterrand
jamais 2011 sur l'atténuation de peine
et l'indignation de peine oui pour des
malades mentaux et le renforcement des
obligations de soins le gouvernement
déposé un amendement sur ce sujet que
nous verrons également demain en
commission des lois enfin je voudrais
pour terminer faire trois remarques et
formulé une conclusion
tout d'abord madame la ministre vous
savez très bien la loi ne servira à rien
c'est le gouvernement néglige pas les
moyens nécessaires notamment en
personnel pour 2 et de services de
probation le gouvernement a pris des
engagements clairs dans le cadre de ce
projet de loi notamment quand on
recrutement de 1000 personnels
supplémentaires sur trois ans 400 ont
déjà été recrutés il faut que ces
engagements soient respectés c'est le
gage du succès de ce texte car si ce
texte devait échouer ça serait
absolument dramatique pour la suite à
mon avis je vous rappelle que c'est loi
pénitentiaire est aujourd'hui mal
appliquées ou peu appliquée c'est
notamment parce que les postes
supplémentaires qui avait été annoncé
par le précédent gouvernement n'ont pas
été créés
l'objectif annoncé est de parvenir à un
ratio je dirais de 40 mesures par
conseillers de probation il faut qu'ils
soient tenues si l'on veut que ces
mesures de milieux ouverte fonctionne la
seconde condition préalable à
l'application de cette loi est relative
à une nécessaire rénovation des méthodes
de travail des services de probation
cette question suscite beaucoup
d'inquiétude chez les personnels
j'allais tous entendu mais elle doit
aboutir pour faire de la probation une
alternative véritablement crédible à la
détention cela n'empêche pas que les
personnels des services de probation
sont des personnels fonctionnaires
qu'ils exercent un service public mais
qu' ils peuvent être je dirais et d
accompagner entouré par le milieu
associatif par exemple comme c'est le
cas en matière de mineurs ou les
fonctionne de la pjj honte à côté d'eux
toute une série d'associations habilité
qui font le même travail que enfin il
est nécessaire mais vous avez parlé
madame la garde des sceaux au cours de
votre audition devant la commission
d'améliorer l'évaluation des politiques
pénales en matière de sécurité
les nombreuses lois votées au cours des
dix dernières années se sont fait
presque aveugle sans évaluation
préalable quand l'outil d'évaluation est
défaillant ce cela est largement
imputable aux outils statistiques
du ministère de l'intérieur d'abord et
jusqu'à une date récente du ministère de
la justice il faut absolument les
améliorer le décret prévu par l'article
7 de la loi pénitentiaire qui prévoit
une évaluation de la récidive par
établissements pour peine est toujours
pas été publiés et le garde des sceaux a
annoncé et vous avez annoncé récemment
la création d'une réforme est la
création d'un observatoire de la
récidive et des résistances totalement
indépendant du gouvernement souhaitons
qu'il soit bientôt mise en place et
qu'elle si on est un système
d'évaluation fiable et indépendants des
instances gouvernementales
enfin la conclusion que je voudrais
faire concerne le pseudo laxisme de ce
projet de loi alors voilà un terme que
j'entends répété à longueur
d'émissions de télévision que je lis à
longueur de phrases d'un atome de
journaux et je voudrais dire que ce qui
serait laxiste
ça serait de ne rien faire
de redresser les choses en état de
continuer à remplir les prisons au delà
de ce qu'elles peuvent contenir de
continuer à y faire rentrer des gens
pour des courtes peines pour lesquelles
on ne sait très bien aucune mesure
d'accompagnement des possible de
continuer à voir 90% du säntis sèche
pour les peaux les emprisonnements de
moins de 6 mois de continuer à voir
procédurale à un taux de récidive qui
est à peu près de 70% et de continuer à
avoir des victimes supplémentaires voilà
c'est ça le laxisme ci se satisfaire
une situation qui n'est pas tenable
et au contraire la responsabilité
l'efficacité la prise de conscience et
le courage c'est de proposer autre chose
c'est ce que se propose de projet de loi
je souhaite qu'il réussisse je souhaite
madame le garde des sceaux et vous aussi
que le gouvernement y mettre les moyens
matériels et je pense que au bénéfice de
ses observations je vous invite mes
chers collègues adopté le projet de loi
dans le texte est issu des travaux de
votre commission des lois vous remercie
merci monsieur le rapporteur la parole
est à monsieur jean pierre sueur
président de la commission des lois
bon
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues
non à l'impunité
je veux dire fortement non à l'impunité
l'impunité
est délétère
lundi l'impunité brise la confiance en
la justice
nous sommes nous sommes donc ici
rassemblés pour parler de ce texte de
loi dont le but est de mettre fin à
l'impunité et je commence par ou jean
pierre michel a excellemment conclu
mes chers collègues
si nous voulons qu'il n'y ait plus
d'impunité
chacun comprend qu'il faut que tout
délit toute infraction donne lieu à une
sanction
et si l'on veut que tout délit toute
infraction donne lieu à une sanction
il faut qu'il y ait une pluralité de
sanctions et la prison ne peut être la
seule peine possible même si certains
pensent cela c'est faux c'est un
fantasme il faut il y est une diversité
des peines et c'est pourquoi je rends
hommage bien sûr avoue même madame la
ministre d'avoir présenté proposé
travailler pour arriver à ce projet de
loi est un autre rapporteur jean-pierre
michel qui a été totalement fidèle à
l'esprit du texte
l'esprit du texte c'est qu'il y aura
trois types de peines distinctes voilà
et que la contrainte pénale sera une
vraie peine à côté des deux autres
la détention et la mode alors moi aussi
j'ai lu les titres de ce journal du
matin qui a
dénoncé sur six ou sept colonnes la
gauche anti prison
qui traite une insulte est une imposture
je le dénonce
nous ne sommes pas contre la prison nous
pensons que la prison est nécessaire que
la prison est une institution
républicaine nous visitons assez les
prisons pour savoir le travail difficile
qu'accomplissent les personnels
pénitentiaires et nous leur rendons
hommage parce que leur tâche est rude
elle est difficile les prisons sont
nécessaires pour protéger pour punir et
pour réinsérer mais il n'est pas
possible que la seule peine soit la
prison et dire parce que on préconise
qu'il y ait d'autres peinent à côté de
la prison que nous sommes anti prison
c'est une imposture intellectuelle
et tout le monde le comprend et aux
auteurs du titre je demande de nous
expliquer comment ils peuvent dire cela
dire que parce qu'il y à d'autres peines
on est contre la prison c'est simplement
jouer sur un certain nombre d'émotions
élémentaire ah oui on va plus mettre les
gens en prison mais nous voulons nous
que la prison soit une prison
républicaine où il ya des conditions de
vie qui soit différente comme le dit la
loi pénitentiaire et sa demande des
moyens et nous en sommes d'accord et
surtout où l'on puisse se réinsérer et
alors moi je pose aux auteurs du titre
et des articles et des campagnes et des
polémiques et qui chaque fois que madame
christiane taubira ouvre la bouche 10
laxisme ce qui est un réflexe pavlovien
qui est tout à fait méprisable je le dis
ici parce que je le pense profondément
je dis la chose suivante
le nombre de peines
d'emprisonnement ferme
est important suite en particulier aux
lois qui ont été votées
par les gouvernements précédents
par le parlement et monsieur y est vous
avez monsieur le président cent fois
raison
vous avez tout à fait raison donc par la
majorité précédente
simplement
je veux dire que selon les chiffres
officiels une peine d'emprisonnement
ferme sur deux est mise en oeuvre entre
4 et 60 mois c'est dans le rapport de
monsieur raimbourg auxquels je rends
hommage à mon tour
la moitié des peines d'emprisonnement
ferme sont mises en oeuvre plus de sept
mois après avoir été prononcé
le taux de mise en exécution
des peines de détention ferme en 2012 et
2 56% c'est à dire qu'il y a
44% des peines qui ne sont pas exécutées
ça veut dire mes chers collègues
qu'après avoir entendu tous les discours
de l'exécutif précédent
la réalité c'est qu'à la fin de l'année
2012 il y avait exactement
99 1600 personnes qui avaient été
condamnés à de la prison ferme et qui
circulaient dans les rues qui n'était
pas en prison c'est la réalité alors aux
auteurs du fameux titre et des articles
et des campagnes jeudi pourquoi n'avez
vous jamais écrit qu'une politique qui
aboutit à ce que près de cent mille
personnes soient condamnés à la prison
ferme et circulent dans les rues et
n'exécute aucune peine pourquoi n'avez
vous pas dit que cela était laxiste
parce que cela est laxiste et par
conséquent ce projet de loi il vise à
mettre fin à ce laxisme par une
diversité des peines par des peines
appropriées par des peines
individualise et que nous sortions de
cette grande difficulté qui est
qu'aujourd'hui
ou plutôt il y a quelques semaines les
chiffres sont du 1er mai 2014 il y avait
en france 80 1 mille cinquante trois
personnes sous écrou et 68 1645
personnes détenues jamais on n'avait
atteint un tel score jamais par le passé
alors nous construisons de nouvelles
prisons et vous l'avez dit madame la
ministre et le chiffre figure il a été
annoncé donc nous ne sommes pas du tout
anti prison mais nous voulons que la
prison assume sa mission dans de bonnes
conditions
je terminerai en disant que nous sommes
et jean-pierre michel l'a très bien
expliqué dans la fidélité à la loi
pénitentiaire
je rappelle ceci elle a été votée dans
les conditions que vous savez par le
sénat
je dirais ceci souvenez vous qu'il est
écrit dans la loi pénitentiaire
je cite en matière correctionnelle en
dehors des condamnations récidive légale
prononcé en application de l'article 130
de 19,1
une peine d'emprisonnement sans sursis
ne peut être prononcée qu'en dernier
recours si la gravité de l'infraction et
la personnalité de son auteur rendent
cette peine nécessaire et si toute autre
sanction est manifestement inadéquates
et je dis que l'on a bien fait sous le
gouvernement précédent d'adopter cela
mais dans ce cas là il faudrait dire
aussi que c'est laxiste cela pourtant
c'est la réalité et c'est le bien il
faut que la prison elle soit décidée
quand c'est nécessaire et quand donc les
autres peines et en particulier la
contrainte pénale ne peuvent pas être
mises en oeuvre
je cite aussi s'agissant de cette
bizarrerie qui consisterait à revenir
sur le seuil à 2 ans qui permettait de
bénéficier d'un aménagement de peine et
à un an d'emprisonnement pour les
récidivistes à ce que disait notre
ancien collègue robert badinter ge site
il a fait part de son opposition à une
telle disposition en estimant que
redescendre à 1 en aurait d'autres
effets que d'ajouter quelques milliers
de détenus à la population carcérale
tout le bénéfice de la suppression des
peines plancher se volatilisera alors
mes chers collègues je pense que le
texte tel que nous
l'avons proposé en commission des lois à
la suite d'un long débat de beaucoup
d'auditions de beaucoup de travail j'en
remercie une fois encore notre
rapporteur ce texte madame la ministre
il est fidèle à cette démarche sans
précédent
que vous avez menées qui a été la
conférence de consensus sa préparation
sa tenue son suivi
l'idée que la contrainte pénale soit une
peine spécifique répondant à des délits
spécifiques
elle est totalement dans l'esprit du
texte et nous pensons que nous servons
la république en servant l'esprit du
projet de loi tel qu'il a été préparé
c'est pourquoi en appelant moi aussi eu
nos collègues en vous appelant à voter
ce texte je tiens à faire de ce vote un
hommage à votre action et à l'esprit de
la loi l'esprit des lois auxquelles vous
êtes attachés et que nous partageons
totalement madame la ministre
merci monsieur le président dans la
suite de la discussion générale la
parole est à monsieur jean jacques hyest
pour le groupe ump
notamment
j'ai pris le bénin
monsieur le président madame la garde
des sceaux mes chers collègues
alors le projet de loi que nous avons
examinés à une caractéristique
il ya eu un très long débat à il était
déposé le 13 octobre les trades et pis
là on va faire ça
il ya des idées débat il semble au sein
du gouvernement il paraît qu'ils ne sont
même pas complètement terminée mais je
ne sais rien de tout ça
non mais je le dis j'ai bien le droit
c'est pas faux c'est pas un journal du
matin qui le dit nous avons des sources
autres
par contre examen est précipitée et je
crois que la tête de cet important c'est
quand même une des premières fois où il
n'y aura qu'une lecture dans chaque
assemblée
c'est une et c'est une des premières et
ça paraît quand même extraordinaire
parce que vous le savez bien madame le
garde des sceaux c'est que le dialogue
c'est aussi dans la navette
ci a pas de navette le dialogue se
termine vite on fait ça là sera vous
table en cmp peut-être y aura-t-il un
accord et on nous demande de boucler ce
texte avant la fin de la session alors
nous nous le souhaitons pour vous parce
que ça vous permettra de prendre
quelques repos quand même vous méritez
bien ça oui mais vous peut-être quand
même prendre quelques jours quand il
faut que la loi sera peut-être voter
mais il est vrai que depuis toujours on
nous a dit on à la bouche la conférence
de consensus alors certes
mais c'est quand même le parlement qui
vote les lois
et surtout le jury de consensus qui m'a
paru quand même très unilatérale
et dès lors le parlement il n'a plus
qu'à s'en remettre aux spécialistes de
la question
d'ailleurs on ne sait pas très bien dans
le projet de loi s'il s'agit de lutter
contre la récidive
c'était le texte initial du projet de
loi quel texte initial
ou de renforcer l'efficacité des
sanctions pénales c'est le nouveau terme
qui est celui du tech qui nous a été
transmis par l'assemblée nationale
non mais c'est pas pareil
les mots ont un sens quand même quelque
part et d'opposer bien sûr la soi disant
politique du tout répressif de la
majorité précédente et l'humanisme de
bon aloi des promoteurs de ce projet de
loi
en dehors de quelques incongruités votée
par l'assemblée nationale
telle la transaction pénale conférait un
officier de police judiciaire
en lisant schoch n'a été surpris
la géo localisation et l'interception
des correspondances de personnes
condamnées sortante détention d'ailleurs
on pourrait se demander quelle est la
nature de ces interceptions de sécurité
on et vous savez dans ce domaine il faut
être extrêmement vigilant
surtout quand on nous oppose la
surveillance de sûreté je trouve quand
même que c'est un petit paradoxe que les
députés n'ont certainement pas vu quel
est le fond de la réforme dont on nous
dit bien sûr qu'elle est comme toute
réforme ambitieuse
et permettra de régler à la fois le
problème de la surpopulation carcérale
est celui de la récidive
c'est vrai que coeur du dispositif c'est
l'article 10 du projet de loi qui
prévoit l'alternative à l'emprisonnement
constitue la contrainte pénale notion
qui après avoir lu et relu est un peu
flou parce qu'on n'a pas vraiment le
contenu
franchement par rapport à l'article 131
3 du code pénal actuel quoi nouveau sous
le soleil et je ne vous souhaite pas la
diversité des peines alternatives à
l'emprisonnement qui figure mais à la
suite du code pénal je ne vous
infligerez parce que vous le connaissez
tous par coeur tout la section 2 du
titre iii intitulé des peines
le code pénal
même quand il a été révisé et j'ai
participé à l'époque s'est d'ailleurs
bien gardé de donner une définition de
la peine
mais le projet de loi une fois de plus
bavard parce que quand tu sais ça passe
ça doit figurer dans les textes de
réflexion la philosophie etc
n'a pas résisté à la tentation d'une
définition dont on distingue mal
d'ailleurs dans son texte le but de la
peine et la fonction de la peine
et qui avec un zeste de droits reconnus
à la victime quand même on leur a ajouté
mélange la sanction nécessaire et
l'individuel et l'individualisation pour
permettre le retour dans la société de
celui qui enfreint des règles
essentielles que le code pénal
sanctionne
pour en revenir au centre du débat et
même si je ne suis aucunement d'accord
avec notre rapporteur
aucunement d'accord monsieur le
rapporteur
je reconnais que vous suivez la logique
initiale du tech
ayant bien vu que la contrainte pénale
est un succédané du sursis avec mise à
l'épreuve et non pas une sanction
autonome
avez vous le courage de nous dire que
l'emprisonnement
ne s'appliquent plus à des délits punis
de cinq ans d'emprisonnement puisque
j'étais sale départ certes monsieur le
rapporteur vous l'avez limitée à
quelques délits
et pourquoi pas ultérieurement
d'ailleurs disant
je résiste à la tentation de vous citer
certaines ces délits notamment ceux
contre les personnes qui seraient
concernées
en dehors de ce point crucial qui ne
saurait entraîner notre adhésion à votre
projet et je vous démontrerait qu'il en
est nul besoin pour éviter le tout
carcéral vous reprochez que l'on
distingue le sens réservées aux
récidivistes et aux primo-délinquants
toutes les dispositions du projet de loi
veulent d'ailleurs contrat le juge a
notifié une sanction d'autres
d'emprisonnement car
si certains sont adeptes des peines
planchers il semble que certains autres
sont adeptes des peines place aux
je rappelle que les pensions ont été
validés par le conseil constitutionnel
ce va rien dire pour monsieur michel
pour moi je respecte bien entendu les
décisions du conseil constitutionnel
ça n'entrave en rien la personnalisation
de la peine et il est évident que juges
ont utilisé la peine minimale de façon
de mesurer justifié je vous renvoie
aussi de vote de la chancellerie madame
le garde des sceaux mais c'est un a
priori idéologiques il y ait de votre
démarche qu'une véritable politique de
lutte contre la récidive j'en veux pour
preuve l'extraordinaire article 3 du
projet qui oblige le juge a motivé
spécialement sa décision de prononcer
une peine d'emprisonnement
heureusement mais je réagis reviendrait
il ya la possibilité matérielle qui
permettent aux juges de faire ce qu'il
veut et pourtant le juge conscient de
ses responsabilités ne fait appliquer le
code pénal quel méfiance envers les
juges et un certain nombre d'entre eux
s'en sont à juste titre ému
en matière de procédure pénale tout
projet de loi est révélateur d'une
politique il en est que la traduction
juridique
outre la complication extrême du
dispositif qui repose largement sur le
juge de l'application des peines et
d'ailleurs vous avez modifié à certains
de choses dans ce domaine parce que
quand même ça pose un problème il n'a
qu'un seul objectif sous-entendu lutter
contre la surpopulation carcérale
certains diraient vider les prisons et
d'ailleurs je n'aime pas les exemples
les comparaisons forcément international
faire les exemples donnés de certaines
politiques pénales d'europe du nord font
rêver puisqu'il va apparemment ni ferme
des prisons
on oublie de dire que le taux de
récidive n'est pas si faible qu'on le
prétend dans ce cas-là forail infos
toujours modérée des choses et c'est
vrai que les prisons dès que j'ai visité
des pelles europe du nord ont une
dignité que n'ont pas beaucoup de nos
établissements pénitentiaires
si le sénat n'a cessé d'affirmer depuis
la commission d' enquête sur les prisons
de 2000 et surtout à l'occasion de la
loi pénitentiaire de 2009 et le dit
madame le garde des sceaux vous m'avez
cité tout à l'heure que les courtes
peines d'emprisonnement et est peu
efficace
et même plutôt nuisibles
tels étaient plus fin plus tôt facteur
de récidive que d'amendements la vraie
question qui se pose est de savoir
pourquoi la loi n'est pas ou peu
appliquée et je vous renvoie puisque le
g par lire la citation du président sur
tout à l'heure que l'article 65 de la
loi pénitentiaire que vous trouvez dans
l'article 132 24 du code pénal qui
prévoit effectivement que pour les
peines d'emprisonnement
sans sursis
elle peut être prononcée qu'en dernier
recours tout est là pourquoi vouloir
inventer quelque chose de nouveau alors
que nous avons déjà tous les outils tous
les outils juridiques pour permettre de
ne pas incarcérer des primo délinquants
et madame le garde des sceaux c'est
jusqu'à 2 ans d'emprisonnement
d'ailleurs je ne sais pas pourquoi les
députés ont été inventés qu'il fallait
réduire un an et six mois ce alors là je
ne je ne comprends pas vous peut-être
quelqu'un mais expliquera-t-il
telle elle quelle est la cohérence de
cèpes décision
et je rappelle en plus que le code de
procédure pénale
prévoit que les cons d'un délit
bénéficie dans la mesure du possible si
leur personnalité ou leur situation le
permettent de mesures d'aménagement de
peine
la semi-liberté le placement à
l'extérieur placement sous surveillance
électronique
fractionnement sus temps sur la peine
libération de conditionnel ou même la
conversion en travail d'intérêt général
il en est de même pour les personnes
déjà incarcérées et cela pour toutes les
peines prononcées de moins de deux ans
certains voulaient réduire à une
certaine époque le sénat s'est battu
pour maintenir que pour maintenir la
peine de deux ans jean rené lecerf s'en
souvient et d'autres aussi
est de mon point de vue cela couvre
largement les mesures proposées par le
projet de loi pour la contrainte pénale
je me permets de rappeler mais vous
l'avez fait les uns et les autres que
dans un moment rare devant un parlement
un véritable consensus parlementaire a
existé lors du vote de la loi
pénitentiaire
et que l'échec de sa mise en oeuvre est
liée au manque de moyens pour assurer
son effectivité on peut leur reprocher
au gouvernement précédent mais pourquoi
ça n'a pas été une priorité de votre
politique pénale madame le garde des
sceaux immédiatement de mettre les
moyens nécessaires pour son application
si on la trouve bonne cette loi je pense
que personne ne la trouvent mauvaise
pourquoi n'at-on pas mises en oeuvre
immédiatement
et je vous le dis franchement
non non il n'y avait pas que ce n'était
pas une question de degré d'application
c'était surtout une question des moyens
des spip vous le savez très bien ça a
été évoqué et à lire les l'étude
d'impact de votre projet de loi madame
le garde des sceaux
et les gares et les restrictions
budgétaires on peut être optimiste car
nous pouvons contraindre que la
contrainte pénale ne soit pas la grande
réforme doit inventer des deux attendait
des résultats puisqu'il paraît que c'est
entre 16000 et 60000 condamné c'est
votre étude d'impact avez-vous vrai
véritablement les moyens de créer si on
va jusqu'au bout les plus de 1000
emplois on nous avait dit la même chose
pour une loi pénitentiaire mille emplois
la réponse est évidemment négative et ce
qui est extraordinaire dans notre beau
pays de france et de croire qu'en
faisant une loi de plus qui obscurcit
puisqu'elle ne simplifient la lisibilité
des politiques de l'état on va résoudre
tous les problèmes on fait des lois on
en fait tout le temps et on pense qu'on
va améliorer les choses ce n'est pas en
calquant les régimes de sanctions des
récidivistes sur celui des primo
délinquants
ni la procédure obligatoire d'examen de
la situation des personnes condamnées à
plus de cinq ans d'emprisonnement
à 2-1 à peine qui changeront grand chose
encore faudrait-il avoir les moyens on
juge donc etc mais au contraire cela ne
va pas améliorer la situation explosive
de notre système judiciaire
la contrainte pénale faux jumeaux de
sursis probatoire ça c'est les termes de
la commission nationale consultative des
droits de l'homme pensent selon elle un
sérieux problème de justice et
lisibilité
pourquoi créer en plus compliqué ce que
difficilement applicable quand on
constate que près de cent mille peines
correctionnelles médical des hug 1600 ne
sont pas exécutées pouvons nous espérer
que la création debeix viraux
d'exécution des peines suffisent assurer
une meilleure efficacité des sanctions
pénales comme tous ceux qui croient
l'individualisation de la peine au fait
que l'emprisonnement n'est pas la
solution unique pour les délinquants et
d'ailleurs vous devriez revisiter la
notion de récidive
on y rit on en parle quelquefois qui on
n'avance pas sur ce sujet je crois que
les moyens juridiques existent pour
faciliter l'insertion ou la réinsertion
des condamnés
au lieu de se lancer dans des guerres
idéologiques dont nous avons le secret
mieux faudrait surtout appliquer les
textes existants et qui examinait sur le
long terme présente quoi qu'on en dise
une certaine continuité
n'est ce n'est pas la notion de justice
restaurative qui peut avoir un intérêt
certain dans le cadre d'un traitement
psychologique n'est pas dans celui de la
justice qui aura des effets évidents
quoi qu'il en soit je ne peux que le
répéter et le rapport nos collègues
lecerf fait madame borvo cohen seat sur
l'application de la peine doit
pénitentiaire est éloquente à ce sujet
finirons nous par changer la prison
non pas parce que
la loi ne prévoit pas tous les
dispositifs mais parce qu'on lui donnera
les moyens de jouer pleinement son rôle
de préparation à la réinsertion des
détenus dans la société
combien de sorties sèches
génère-t-elle de récidive comment faire
pour que les maisons d'arrêt ne même
plus des détenus provisoires des grands
criminels en attente
d'établissement pour penn et cette masse
de délinquants qui re devrait recevoir
un traitement adapté et sans parler tous
ceux qui sont atteints de troubles
mentaux et pour qui la prison n'est pas
non plus la solution
alors ce projet de loi
dont on peut contester le soubassement
idéologique
la petite chanson c'est la société qui
fait la délinquance s'est pas
complètement fou mais c'est pas
complètement vrai manque sa cible est
rejetée par la majorité de l'opinion
publique même si elle est
si les journaux ne clarifie pas
complètement le sens de votre projet et
pour ces raisons malgré quelques points
positifs
issus des propositions de loi du sénat
notamment ne saurait hélas madame le
garde des sceaux être approuvée par mon
gros
merci la parole est à monsieur yves
detraigne pour le groupe eut des uc
monsieur le président madame la garde
des sceaux monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur le président de la commission
richard collègues comment ne pas
partager les autres objectifs affichés
de votre réforme madame la ministre
votre texte vise à je cite l'exposé des
motifs lutter contre la récidive
moderniser et clarifier le droit des
peines et leurs modalités de mise en
oeuvre naturellement nous partageons
tous ici ses objectifs il ressemble
d'ailleurs sensiblement à ceux qui ont
présidé à l'élaboration de la loi
pénitentiaire de 2009
malheureusement madame la ministre je
crains que votre projet loi n'atteignent
pas tout à fait ses objectifs
commençons par la contrainte pénale qui
est en quelque sorte la mesure
emblématique de votre réforme
j'évoquerai tout à l'heure le fond de la
mesure en disant que nous n'y sommes pas
fondamentalement opposés mais sur la
forme il est difficile d'admettre que
rajouter une nouvelle forme de peine au
maquis qui existe déjà soit je cite
source de clarification du droit des
peines surtout quand même les
spécialistes ont du mal à comprendre
précisément sa nature tant elle
s'apparente dans ses modalités a des
éléments déjà existants je pense
évidemment au sursis avec mise à
l'épreuve il est invoqué ensuite la
nécessité d'individualiser les peines
principes fondateurs de notre droit
pénal mais ne le sont elles pas déjà
les magistrats ne dispose-t-il pas des
outils juridiques leur permettant
d'apporter une réponse adaptée aux
circonstances de l'infraction et à la
personnalité de son auteur je pense que
si en réalité sur cet aspect vous avez
certainement en tête un des marqueurs de
la majorité précédente les peines
plancher
non les peines planchers ne sont pas
contraires au principe de
l'individualisation des peines
d'ailleurs moins de 40% des prévenus
passive de ses peines se dévoie
appliquée en revanche contrairement à ce
qui est affirmé elles ont un effet
dissuasif
peut-être pas sur tous les délinquants
bien sûr mais je suis certain que dans
un contentieux de masse par exemple
comme celui délits routiers un
automobiliste qui se retrouve face au
président du tribunal correctionnel qui
l'avertît que co prochaine et car il
encourt une peine plancher l'effet
dissuasif est réel autre pilier de votre
réforme je cite construire un parcours
d'exécution des peines là encore c'est
un bel objectif et nous isc souscrivons
tous la réalité c'est que cette
problématique ne tient pas tant à ce
qu'on pourrait modifier dans le code
pénal mais d'abord et avant tout et là
je vais confirmer ce que disait notre
rapporteur tout à l'heure aux moyens
qu'on prévoit d'y consacrer c'est selon
nous le coeur du problème
rapporteur pour avis des programmes
justice judiciaires aient accès au droit
et à la justice pendant plusieurs années
je sais évidemment que notre justice
manque aujourd'hui cruellement de moyens
des moyens pour effectuer certains actes
d'investigation pour rémunérer des
experts judiciaires ou même pour
travailler simplement dans des
conditions normales aujourd'hui la
réalité quotidienne de nombreux
magistrats c'est qu'on finit par compter
les gommes ou les ramettes de papier
sans parler du manque de magistrats à
tous les niveaux notamment de de
juge d'application des peines de
greffiers ou de conseillers d'insertion
et de probation ces derniers seront
pourtant un des piliers de la mise en
oeuvre de votre réforme qui devra pour
être crédible disposer des moyens
indispensables à sa bonne application
sans moyens suffisants cette réforme
sera un échec et de la même manière
qu'on se plaint de la surpopulation
carcérale en raison d'un manque de place
dans les prisons et de la promiscuité
néfastes que cela provoque on risque
demain si les moyens ne sont pas assurés
dans la durée de se plaindre de l' échec
cruel des nouvelles peines proposées
pire même si un délinquant qui exécute
sa peine à l'extérieur se retrouve livré
à lui-même et récidive la loi apparaîtra
alors comme une lois laxistes
ce n'est pas votre souhait madame la
ministre ce n'est pas votre souhait
monsieur le rapporteur nil autre mais
malheureusement je crains fort que la
nécessaire rigueur budgétaire nécessaire
rigueur budgétaire l'emportent sur les
intentions les bonnes intentions qui
sont assis la difficulté qui d'ailleurs
n'est pas propre à ce projet de loi
c'est qu'on nous propose une réforme
avec des engagements sur des
financements à venir sans avoir la
certitude que ces financements soient
effectivement adoptés pour en revenir au
texte quelques mots sur le principe de
la contrainte pénale nouvel outil offert
aux juges il est difficile de dire qu'on
est fondamentalement contre risque il
reprend les obligations et interdictions
qui existent aujourd'hui avec le sursis
avec mise à l'épreuve le sm eu une
certaine façon être contre la contrainte
pénale ça reviendrait être contre le
sursis avec mise à l'épreuve
cette nouvelle peine d'un type
particulier ne peut avoir vocation à
s'appliquer qu'avec certains profils del
un délinquant lorsqu'elle est vraiment
adapté à ce profil dans la pratique
madame la ministre la vraie question est
de savoir si les magistrats qui sont
habitués au fonctionnement du sm à du
sursis avec mise à l'épreuve vont
réellement percevoir la plus value de la
contrainte pénale ça ne me paraît pas
évident si tel n'est pas le cas
l'adoption de cette mesure pourrait
rester assez vaine peu convaincu par le
compromis adopté par l'assemblée
nationale qui prévoit une application
l'ensemble des délits à compter du 1er
janvier 2017 nous vous proposerons d'en
revenir un contraintes pénale
strictement applicable aux délits punis
de moins de cinq ans d'emprisonnement
le texte adopté par les députés au delà
de la contrainte pénale était déjà
critiquable selon nous le texte que nous
examinons aujourd'hui celui élaboré par
notre commission des lois est presque je
dirais caricatural parmi les marqueurs
que vous vouliez absolument supprimer
outre les peines plancher que j'ai déjà
évoqué voilà qu'on supprime aussi la
rétention de sûreté et les tribunaux
correctionnels pour mineurs tout cela
semble découler d'une même logique qui
guide la majorité depuis mai 2012
détricoter toutes les réformes de la
précédente majorité sans toujours
reposer quelque chose de crédible à sa
place avec la modification introduite à
l'article 8 ter vous avez modifié
monsieur le rapporteur la nature même de
la contrainte pénale en effet la
contrainte pénale était présenté comme
une nouvelle possibilité offerte aux
juges en complément des possibilités
déjà existantes d'accroître sa liberté
de choix et de trouver une réponse plus
adaptée aux circonstances et à la perse
et à la personnalité de l'auteur les
dispositions introduites à l'article 8
ter font le contraire elle supprime la
peine de référence actuellement vigueur
l'emprisonnement pour imposer pour
imposer la contrainte pénale il s'agit
en fait d'une atteinte à la libre
appréciation du juge
le système proposé fait donc disparaître
la peine de prison on n'aurait pu
imaginer qu'elle perdure au moins
encadré ci div mais il n'en est rien
cinq ou six récidive de vol
l'emprisonnement ne pourra toujours pas
être prononcée par le tribunal
correctionnel
et ça c'est un vrai problème à mon sens
la solution retenue est révélatrice du
peu de confiance que vous avez dans le
dispositif de peur que les magistrats
n'y recourent pas suffisamment on le
leur impose une certaine manière au delà
on ne peut pas faire abstraction du
message qui est envoyé à nos concitoyens
lorsque l'on décide de supprimer les
peines d'emprisonnement pour délit de
vol et recel de vol pour filouterie pour
destruction dégradation des
d'orientation pour délit de fuite pour
délit d' usage de stupéfiants délit
d'occupation des halls d'immeuble ou
encore les délits prévus par le code de
la route le travail réalisé par notre
rapporteur a été très important sur ce
texte je tiens à le dire et même si je
ne partage pas la plupart de ces
analyses je tiens en salué le sérieux et
la précision chacun aura compris que
nous ne sommes pas favorables à
plusieurs des modifications introduites
par la commission mais il ne faut pas
comme on dit jeter le bébé avec l'eau du
bain plusieurs amendements visait à
revenir au texte de la loi pénitentiaire
et nous les avons sous je ne citerai que
les seuils d'aménagement des peines
d'emprisonnement
l'assemblée avait uniformiser ses seuils
faisant ainsi disparaître toute
distinction entre primo délinquant
récidiviste
rétablir cette distinction était
indispensable il faut donc saluer
l'initiative de notre rapporteur sur ce
point en conclusion nous étions
sceptiques sur le texte voté par les
députés
après l'examen en commission je dois
dire que nous sommes un peu dépité pour
être clair si à l'issue de nos débats le
projet de loi n évolue pas sensiblement
notamment avec l'adoption de nos
amendements qui pour certains devraient
avoir l'appui du gouvernement puisqu'il
vise à revenir au texte initial nous
voterons contre ce texte en regrettant
notamment les abrogation des peines
planchers et de la rétention de sûreté
en revanche c'est après avoir voté nos
amendements nous aboutissons un texte
équilibré qui permettent effectivement
d'améliorer la lutte contre la récidive
notre position sera susceptible
d'évoluer je vous remercie de votre
attention
merci la parole et à madame cécile
cukierman pour le groupe crc
monsieur le président madame la garde
des sceaux mes chers collègues
l'histoire du droit pénal et un dans le
parti celle de la répression de la
récidive cette histoire se répète
pourtant elle est jonché des chèques
sous l'ancien régime français les
anciennes coutumes en vigueur avant les
grandes ordonnance royale prévoyait par
exemple qu'à la deuxième condamnation
pratiquer les souris mans c'est à dire
qu ont coupé une oreille aux délinquants
à la troisième condamnation il n'y avait
pas de rémission le voleur était
définitivement et souriez pour ne pas
avoir entendu ce qui lui était reproché
puis pendus la relégation demeure la
sanction la plus connue en matière de
lutte contre la récidive
introduite en france par une loi du 27
mai 1885 elle avait pour objectif majeur
d'éloigner le plus longtemps possible
les récidivistes de la ville ces lois
partait toute de l'idée que ces
récidivistes et est incorrigible
irrécupérable et qu'il fallait les
éliminer ou du moins les éloigner sans
se soucier des suites
malheureusement il n'est nul besoin de
remonter loin dans notre histoire pour
rencontrer de nouveau cette philosophie
qui préside encore trop souvent à la
rédaction de nos lois pénales en effet
durant les dernières décennies les faits
divers terreau de la démagogie en ont
justifié un bon nombre renforcement des
sanctions instauration de peines
plancher rétention et surveillance de
sûreté mise en place du tribunal
correctionnel pour mineurs etc autant de
textes utilisés comme des instruments de
communication politique mais qui
aujourd'hui ne parviennent pas à masquer
un bilan particulièrement négatif pour
ne pas dire désastreux si avec ses lois
l'élimination est évidemment plus
physique mais sociale quant à
l'éloignement et sociales pardon cantat
éloignement il se décline sous la
politique du tout enfermement mais il a
échappé à leurs rédacteurs que notre
société a heureusement évolué depuis
1885 et que la plupart des personnes
emprisonnées ressortent un jour dans
notre société en maintenant pourtant la
politique du tout enfermement
d'enfermement qui plus est dans des
conditions
un peu respectueuse des droits de la
personne humaine il est fabriqué ces
récidivistes et c'est exclu qu'ils sont
ensuite montrés du doigt avec ses lois
on s'est contenté d'entasser des
individus dans des mètres carrés mis
pour un temps à l'écart de la société on
a empêché leur réinsertion on les
infantilise ans littéralement quand on
ne les ais brise pas carrément avec des
conditions de détention dégradantes et
je pense que là réside le laxisme n'y a
pas à la fameuse loi pénitentiaire de
2009 encore une bien appliquée à dix et
à certains égards et cela a été rappelé
nous avons ce soir pour la première fois
depuis longtemps un projet de réforme
pénale qui rompt avec cette politique
inefficace aussi bien par la méthode
avec la mise en place d'une conférence
de consensus qui a permis d'avoir un
vrai discours scientifique sur la peine
que par son contenu qui est le
prolongement de ce travail de
concertation
ce projet de loi entend prévenir
efficacement la récidive et donner un
sens à l'appel pour cela il se donne des
objectifs précis sortir du tout carcéral
cela était d'y insister sur la
personnalisation des peines supprimer
les mécanismes automatiques faisant
échec à l'individualisation des peines
construire un parcours d'exécution des
peines efficace dans la prévention des
risques de récidive nous approuvons
l'ensemble de ses objectifs tout d'abord
celui visant à sortir du tout carcéral
vous le savez le taux d'incarcération
n'a cessé d'augmenter 38% depuis dix ans
mais la récidive n'a pas diminué pour
autant bien au contraire ce texte
poursuit dès que la peine n'est plus
synonyme de privation de liberté sa
mesure phare la contrainte pénale et une
peine effectué en milieu ouvert
entièrement tourné vers le suivi
socio-éducatif du condamné elle est
conçue non commun de sanctions moins
sévères contre l'entente parfois que la
peine d'emprisonnement
mais au contraire je pense plus efficace
car plus adapté au traitement de la
plupart des délits qui ont d'ailleurs
été gérée depuis ce soir l'expérience
montre que l'accomplissement d'une peine
en milieu ouvert peut s'avérer plus
contraignantes poing l'individu qu'une
peine de prison en ce qu'elle met à la
charge du condamné une obligation de
résultat celui ci sera absolument tenu
de les injonctions qui lui seront fixés
notamment et une fille née celle d'aller
de l'avant en termes de lutte contre la
récidive elle sera plus efficace qu'une
peine passive effectué en prison dans
les conditions que nous connaissons pour
que cette mesure soit efficace et il ne
faut pas le nier il faut que les moyens
soient donnés aux magistrats aux
conseillers d'insertion et de probation
véritable cheville ouvrière de ce texte
il faudra aussi qu'un important travail
pédagogique soit effectuée par pour que
cette peine soit rapidement approprié
par les magistrats qui devront la
distinguer d'autres mesures telles
notamment le sursis avec mise à
l'épreuve des moyens humains des moyens
financiers sachez madame la garde des
sceaux que nous serons toujours à vos
côtés pour aller dans ce sens et que
nous ne pouvons accepter le statu quo
que nous avons entendues ou sous
prétexte des difficultés budgétaires que
nous dénonçons par ailleurs nous ne
pouvons nous ne pourrions pas évolué la
philosophie de notre droit pénal cette
évolution est en tout cas nécessaire
pour ne pas dire indispensable en ce
début de 21e siècle j'ajouterai un mot
sur l'important travail de notre
rapporteur qui a permis sur ce point de
nourrir le débat
l'adoption de son amendement nous y
reviendrons demain permet de faire de la
contrainte pénal une peine autonome
encourus à titre principal pour une
série de délits précisément identifiés
et pour lesquels la peine
d'emprisonnement ne serait plus en cours
tout comme notre rapporteur je pense que
cette solution permettra d'identifier
clairement la contrainte pénal comme la
nouvelle pelle de référence en matière
correctionnelle le débat de demain nous
permettra d'y revenir mais je peux déjà
dire que cette solution préconisée par
notre reporter à notre faveur en ce sens
qu'elle permet de sauver des germes
destructrice les auteurs de vols simples
de filouterie ou encore les fumeurs
invétérés
et il ne nous semble pas que cette
décision remettent en cause le pouvoir
des juges puisque il leur reviendra
toujours de choisir ou non la
l'utilisation de la contrainte pénale de
l'amande et d'en proposer son
application
tout l'enjeu de la contrainte pénale
n'est-il pas justement de créer une
peine qui permettent d'éviter à ces gens
un passage en prison que nous savons
tous inefficace désocialisant en ce sens
admettent que certains faits de faible
gravité soient punissables d'une
contrainte pénal et non plus de
l'emprisonnement ne nous semble pas
aberrant bien au contraire la prévention
de la récidive passe aussi par là cet
amendement évitera que des petits
délinquants condamnés à de courtes
peines ne ressortent au bout de six mois
endurci par la prison prêt à recommencer
sur d'autres délits d'ailleurs parfois
que celui sur lequel ils ont été
initialement condamnée ce texte % porte
ensuite l'exigence d'une
individualisation de la peine selon la
personnalité du condamné je ne reviens
pas ici sur la suppression du mécanisme
automatique limitant les possibilités
d'individualisation c'est une exigence
porté par notre groupe à travers nos
propositions de loi et vous connaissez
bien évidemment nos positions là dessus
je voudrais par contre souligné une
innovation majeure de ce projet de loi
qui résident dans la césure pénal cette
mesure donnera opportunément le temps de
la réflexion permettant les
investigations qui aideront à décider de
la peine la plus adaptée à la
personnalité du condamné et donc de
mieux prévenir la récidive je n'ai pas
ici le temps de développer l'ensemble
des mesures que nous que nous allions
etc et que nous soutiendrons contre qui
sont contenues dans le texte initial
de ni même celles qui se sont ajoutés
après le trail de notre commission et
sur ce que les projets ne contient pas
mais j'y reviendrai dans le débat
également parce qu'il nous semble
cependant que ce texte aurait pu aller
sur certains points un petit peu plus
loin je prendrais simplement quelques
secondes pour souligner la suppression
de la rétention de sûreté aberrante
peine après la peine ce projet de loi ne
pouvait pas faire l'impasse nous sont
utiles sur sa suppression notre
commission et y remédier pour notre part
il nous semble maintenant indispensable
de supprimer la surveillance de sûreté
de même
on ne pouvait permettre l'oubli de la
justice des mineurs et il ne s'agit pas
là comme cela a été dit de balayer ce
qui a été fait précédemment par principe
mais il nous semble que ne pas
mentionner la justice des mineurs dans
un projet de loi qui concerne
l'individualisation des peines d'une
façon générale et qui s'adresse à
l'ensemble finalement des condamnés
potentiel nous semble un oubli la
commission des lois ainsi procès la
semaine dernière à une première étape
vers la réhabilitation de cette justice
en supprimant les tribunaux
correctionnels pour mineurs on se
souvient que l'instauration de ces
tribunaux sans travail de concertation à
la veille des élections présidentielles
constitua une profonde régression par
rapport aux principes fondateurs de
l'ordonnancé de 1945
la primauté de l'éducatif sur le
répressif
cette ordonnance est et doit rester la
traduction de la volonté de concilier
les exigences des principes
démocratiques de la protection de la
jeunesse et d'une juste répression de la
délinquance des mineurs
notre groupe qui considère que la
priorité éducative n'exclut pas la
fermeté ce fils ici donc de l'adoption
de cet amendement et invite à poursuivre
la réflexion sur la justice des mineurs
et tous fait loi après loi cette
réflexion manque il est vrai qu elle
ment à ce projet de loi mais ne pourra
se résoudre à ce simple projet de loi
est un autre projet est attendu dans ce
domaine enfin dernier point ce texte
disait notre rapporteur prévoit des
dispositions concernant les victimes
elles ne peuvent bien évidemment pas
être mise de côté
j'ajouterai qu'en réalité chacune des
dispositions du texte concerné victimes
car on ne peut s'intéresser aux victimes
sans s'intéresser aux délinquants comme
l'écrit serge portelli spécialiste des
droits des victimes je cite victimes et
coupables appartiennent à la même
humanité questionné l'enfer de la
récidive se demander qui est dans le box
des prévenus c'est aussi aider les
victimes l'erreur jusqu'ici a été de
vouloir diviser cette humanité au gré de
l'actualité
de fait qui révolte bien évidemment
l'opinion publique mais qui pourtant ne
représente qu'une petite part de la
criminalité les expulsions les
exclusions ont été renforcées
en votant ce texte progressiste nous
redonnons à nos juges les outils pour
considérer cette humanité dans toutes
ses composantes pour regarder nos
délinquants autrement qu'à travers un
acte oui mais une énumération d'actes
nous réaffirmons que la peine doit aussi
être un temps pour se reconstruire et se
réinsérer
c'est là le seul moyen efficace pour
lutter contre la récidive que centene
soit en milieu ouvert ou fermé mes chers
collègues le temps de l'estrie mans est
bien loin il nous faut évoluer ce projet
de loi qui a gagné encore en ambition
avec notre commission on est l'occasion
et en est à madame la ministre vous
soutiendront ce projet toi
merci la parole est au président jacques
mézard pour le groupe rdse
monsieur le président madame le garde
des sceaux mes chers collègues
notre groupe votera très majoritairement
ce texte
car nous sommes au bout d'un système
et nous nous ne sommes ni laxiste ni
répressif nous voulons être des hommes
et des femmes de bon sens
la politique pénale pour nous ne saurait
être
simplement une réponse aux faits divers
médiatiques ce que nous avons trop
souvent vécu pendant les années
précédentes
la méthode de la conférence de consensus
qui a présidé à l'élaboration
de ce projet a permis de mettre en
exergue des points de convergence entre
des acteurs d'horizons divers
même si nous déplorons dans la forme
madame la ministre l'engagement de la
procédure accélérée pour ce texte mais
ça c'est une maladie gouvernementales
et nous y reviendrons dans quelques
jours de manière
plus sévère
on peut faire plusieurs constats
le premier et il est il raisonnable
d'entasser davantage de prévenus et de
condamner dans nos prisons la réponse
elle est simple c'est une réponse de bon
sens ce n'est pas possible
la population pénitentiaire
on a vu l'évolution ces dernières années
arrive à une situation qui est devenue
strictement intolérable et la solution
ce n'est pas de construire constamment
des prisons aux nouvelles même si au
niveau
simplement du traitement normal des
condamnés ce serait une bonne chose donc
il faut trouver d'autres solutions
les
précédentes lois jules sous le précédent
quinquennat et je suis souvent intervenu
avec anne marie escoffier avec d'autres
pour dire qu' on était entré dans un
système
de noria c'est à dire qu'il fallait
faire entrer de plus en plus de
condamner en prison pour les faire
sortir de plus en plus rapidement
c'était une aberration dans tous les
sens du terme
en fait la création législatives
françaises en matière de droit pénal a
été tout autant prolixe que brouillonne
laissant les praticiens aux prises avec
les questions de l'utilisation
judiciaire et des modalités concrètes
leur exécution de structures de personal
de personnel et ce brouillage des pistes
a entraîné un véritable épuisement
professionnel des acteurs nous savons
pas ce que c'est une réalité sociale
humaine et que la population pénale et
socialement démunies
simplement un tiers de la population
pénale un emploi avant l'entrée en
prison
70 % un niveau scolaire inférieur au
bepc
et plus de 13% il est trés même si ce
n'est que légèrement supérieur
malheureusement à la moyenne nationale
la conférence de consensus a souligné
les contradictions
d'une politique pénale à la fois tourné
vers la sanction et se donnant pour
objectif de prévenir la récidive il n'y
a pas et nous le savons tous qui avons
l'expérience de ces dossiers il n'y a
pas de véritable corrélation entre la
sévérité de la peine et le taux de
récidive ça c'est une réalité technique
qui est démontré par toutes les études
et par tous les chiffres et alors qu'en
cas de suivi la récidive et 1,6 fois
moindre que pour les sorties sèches 80 %
de personnes sortent de prison sans
suivi il n'y a pas de risque zéro nous
le savons aussi tous
c'est que le crime est inhérent
malheureusement la nature humaine est
l'objet d'une politique pénale c'est de
réduire ce phénomène
constaté je les dis que celle qui a été
menée depuis une dizaine d'années qu'on
va considérer que ce soit une réussite
on peut constater malheureusement que
c'est un échec le traitement de la
récidive a donné lieu à l'adoption d'une
législation trop souvent foisonnante
privilégiant une sévérité accrue comme
moyen de prévention de la récidive et
plaçant l'emprisonnement comme une peine
de référence or pour citer les mots de
monsieur delarue qui est une référence
pour nous
l'efficacité de la prison réside moins
dans le jour de l'entrée que dans le
jour de sortie du condamné
l'indicateur le plus parlant de l'échec
de cette politique est sans doute le
taux d'incarcération qui atteint un
niveau considérable aujourd'hui et ce
taux atteint le niveau d'ailleurs de la
fin du 19e siècle aujourd'hui on à 68000
600 détenus la révision de cette
politique pénale nous le savons tous est
donc nécessaire mais ce qui manque adam
garde des sceaux vous le savez mieux que
nous tous ce sont des moyens financiers
et humains qui ne sont pas au
rendez-vous et si une volonté politique
forte n'est pas associée ce projet se
pourrait se transformer une nouvelle
fois en pansement sur une jambe de bois
cette question de moyens et centrale la
loi pénitentiaire de 2009 va ont tous
dit ici très majoritairement était
porteuse de nombreux espoirs à contre
courant d'ailleurs d'un climat ultra
sécuritaire qui prévalait alors le
parlement avait travaillé dans un esprit
consensuel
elle est malheureusement difficile à
appliquer pour ne pas dire davantage or
la lutte contre la récidive c'est aussi
la nécessité d'améliorer les conditions
de détention
et puis je tiens à faire à
une observation qui m'apparaît
fondamentale madame le garde des sceaux
je suis pas le premier certainement pas
le dernier à la faire c'est que la
politique pénale laisse trop de côté la
question de l'exécution des peines c'est
parfait de faire constamment de
nouvelles lois mais si une république si
un état n'est pas en mesure
d'appliquer les peines que la justice
prononce ça sert pas à grand-chose de
modifier constamment la législation nous
le savons les peines sont souvent
inappliquées inutilisé par le juge ou
exécutées de manière tellement tardive
qu'elles perdent tout leur sens il m'est
arrivé il y a un an de viser ça m'arrive
de temps en temps d'aller à la maison
d'arrêt et de faire ouvrir cellule à la
fois que j'y suis allé il ya plus d'un
an première cellule quand m'ouvre
détenus qui l'attend il me dit mais
j'exécute une peine de 2001
je sais pas si c'est quand même un bon
moyen de faire avancer la justice pénale
donc là dessus nous sommes très en
retard
lorsque les peines sont très éloignées
de la fraction leur sens s'évapore
70% des peines d'emprisonnement
connaissent un délai de mise à exécution
une peine sur 2 émise avant exécution
entre 3,7 et 60 mois soit cinq ans ce
qui correspond des prescriptions en
matière correctionnelle mais si l'on
exclut les peines exécutoire sans délai
la moitié des peines d'emprisonnement
sont mises à exécution à plus de 225
jours
j'ai le sentiment tout en vous disant
que nous considérons que c'est une
amélioration ce projet de loi que ce
projet semble se résigner face à ce
phénomène
et voir l'entériner puisqu'il va jusqu'à
prévoir que les personnes à l'encontre
desquels doivent être mise à exécution
des peines prononcées plus de trois ans
auparavant doivent être préalablement
convoqué par le juge d'application des
peines je crains que l' exécution
tardive est encore de belles années
devant elle croit que le changement
c'est que cette loi s'interroge sur le
sens de l'emprisonnement et qu'elle
rompe avec la politique pénale de ces
dernières années qui a conforté la peine
privative de liberté comme peine de
référence de notre droit pénal car
l'individualisation des peines doit
contribuer à faire baisser le taux
d'incarcération
je suis de ce même si on critique
souvent l'action de la justice je suis
de ceux qui disent qu'il faut faire
confiance aux magistrats
ce n'était pas le cas avec les peines
plancher j'avais déposé une proposition
de loi d'ailleurs pour les supprimer y
compris sur l'appel de la peine de
rétention et de ce point de vue et j'en
termine là dessus le texte déposé à
l'assemblée nationale
contenait une régression à rebours il
revenait sur la loi de 2009 en prévoyant
l'abaissement des seuils d'aménagements
de peines de deux à un an pour les primo
délinquants et d'un an à six mois pour
les récidivistes
la commission des lois est heureusement
revenu à la rédaction de la loi
pénitentiaire de 2009 amour conclure sur
l'instauration de la contrainte pénale
je ne crois pas que ce soit la panacée
c'est un moyen je ne crois pas
d'ailleurs que ça justifie les immenses
débat que l'on a pu lire dans la presse
et en particulier lors la presse
parisienne mais ils en ont l'habitude
mais ce peut être un pas vers la
réinsertion de certains délinquants et à
ce titre là je pense que cela peut
constituer un progrès il est temps
madame le garde des sceaux de mettre fin
au populisme pénal comme l'a rappelé
récemment notre ancien garde des sceaux
et notre ancien collègue robert badinter
le moment est venu de savoir ce que l'on
veut faire une énième loi se fondant
dans le foisonnement législatif ou une
loi qui redéfinit notre droit pour les
années à venir ce texte c'est notre
sentiment ne constitue pas une
révolution il est une évolution rendue
nécessaire par les réalités et c'est
pour cela que nous le voterons
majoritairement je vous remercie
merci monsieur le président la parole
est à madame esther benbassa pour le
groupe écologie
monsieur le président madame la ministre
monsieur le rapporteur mes chers
collègues j'ouvrirai mon intervention
par un mot de paul ricoeur philosophe et
chrétiens dans soi même comme un autre
becker écrit je cite la sagesse pratique
consiste à inventer les conduits qui
satisferont le plus à l'exception que
demande la sollicitude en trahissant le
moins possible la règle pour iccn une
justice seulement des tribus steve reste
en deçà du juste le jugement doit avant
tout contribuer à la paix sociale en
rapprochant les points de vue entre
partageant entre eux le soin de
l'apaisement et du renouvellement du
lien social dans la continuité
d'aristote liqueur appelle à un effort
renouvelé pour ne jamais séparer
l'aspect déontologique de la justice qui
est l'affirmation de règles et
d'obligation de son aspect téléologique
dont la visée consiste en un bien vivre
en commun madame le ministre
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre
le test que vous avez initié constitue
un tournant au regard d'une philosophie
de la justice aspirant à y préserver la
touche d'humanité tout en palliant
l'indifférence aux oubliettes de
l'histoire une philosophie qui est aussi
indignation exigences de défendre les
droits des plus démunis avec et pour eux
si le projet de loi dont nous débattons
réussit à traverser dignement une
atmosphère politique qui est plus à la
polémique qu'a la reconstruction sociale
positive il contribuera à feu r de la
compassion comme s'il a souligné
rousseau dans l'emile non pas une fable
commisération mais une force
susceptibles d'irriguer les liens
sociaux
aussi bien rousseau que ricoeur
réhabilite en effet la compassion comme
composante du lien social démontrant la
force de ce sentiment loin de tout
éphémère sentimentalisme comme de tout
stérile apitoiement votre texte madame
la ministre même incomplets porte aux
l'humanisme qui a longtemps été celui de
notre pays mais que certains de ses
dirigeants tentent parfois à oublier
soumis à la course informations rapides
et sensationnel des médias adepte d'une
philosophie du smartphone et du tweet
qui serait selon le flot du jour à même
de dicter décisions importantes et
mesures prêtes à l'emploi telle cette
utopie de la tolérance zéro à
l'insécurité dans un monde d'humains
vulnérables est faillible
avec ce texte nous nous ouvrons aussi
madame la ministre
au caire anglo américains tels canalisée
par john tronto lequel permet selon elle
la transformation de la pensée sociale
et politique en particulier de la façon
dont nous avons à traiter les autres
c'est à partir de sa pratique se révèle
le mieux les ressources de la compassion
pour tisser des liens sociaux plus
soucieux des besoins des plus démunis et
plus ambitieux dans la défense de leurs
droits
c'est en prenant au sérieux les
pratiques du caire et en les considérant
dans toute l'envergure que son manifeste
la puissance intégrative à cet égard vos
textes madame la ministre est il
parfaitement réaliste
nous écologie sommes heureux et on
aurait d'examiner avec vous toutes et
tous ce projet de loi relative à
l'individualisation des peines et à la
prévention de la récidive qui nous
permet d'être les acteurs d'un tournant
décisif il était temps de mettre fin à
l'aberration des peines plancher ainsi
qu'à la révocation automatique du sursis
simple et du sursis avec mise à
l'épreuve la contrainte pénale l'une des
mesures phares de ce projet de loi a
certes réveillé les démons les plus
puissants de notre imaginaire pénale
pourtant au printemps la conférence de
consensus sur la prévention de la
récidive a démontré chiffres à l'appui
que pour les petites infractions
la récidive était plus faible après une
peine de probation en liberté qu après
un séjour en prison
l'enfermement à tout prix serait-il donc
le seul horizon possible de la peine et
pourquoi la peine de probation serait
tel un cadeau fait aux délinquants
nicole maestracci magis lac président du
comité d'organisation de la conférence
de consensus et a pourtant insisté
la peine y de probation et je la cite
une peine à part entière ajoutant qu'il
convenait de sortir de l'idée que les
peines en milieu ouvert sont plus douces
que l'enfermement
et comme les plis denis salas je le cite
cette peine s'inscrit complètement dans
la philosophie de la réhabilitation
punir c'est d'abord réinjectés dans
l'individu coupable des normes sociales
et non morale la psychanalyse nous a
appris qu'on ne peut pas éradiquer le
désir du mal et qu'il ne sait pas grand
chose de penser qu'on lancera le
délinquant plus vertueux non on peut
essayer de l'insérer dans la société
elle empêcher qu'ils deviennent pires
que ce qu'ils aient comme c'est le cas
justement dans ces prisons ou les petits
délinquants fréquente des bandits
d'envergure ou des djihadistes dans une
promiscuité extrême et dans l'abandon à
soi même il ne s'agit plus d'entretenir
une société sondagière et vengeresse de
l'utopie sécuritaire et du populisme
pénal mais de travailler à l'avènement
d'une société apaisée qui participent
activement à la mise en oeuvre de la
sanction en fait le droit à
l'approbation dire aux coupables tu
seras puni mais tu gardes ta place parmi
nous ou selon ricoeur
par dont denis salas monsieur oui
merci d'intervenir et de compléter ma
culture
où selon rigueur qui dit tu vaux mieux
que tes actes nous sommes aujourd'hui à
la croisée des chemins il nous faut
choisir entre deux options ou construire
de plus en plus de prison où ils ont
forcé les actions éducatives
d'insertion et de solidarité à l'endroit
des délinquantes pour moins de récidive
est plus de sécurité l'autre grande
question bien entendu est de savoir si
pour faire aboutir cette réforme on s'en
donnera les moyens notamment s'agissant
de l'instauration d'un examen
systématique ya la situation des
condamnés à une peine de plus de cinq
ans en vue de l'éventuelle octroi d'une
mesure de libération sous contrainte
mécanisme qui devrait permettre de
lutter efficacement contre les sorties
sèches véritable terreau de la récidive
il ne s'agit pas ici de lâcher les
criminels dans la nature comme certains
le prétendent mais au contraire d'éviter
l'environnement carcéral souvent
criminogènes à certains auteurs
d'infractions qui se veut ont contraint
par de nombreuses obligations et
interdictions adaptés à leur situation
n'oublions pas non plus que l'insertion
commence en milieu fermé aucune mesure
n'a été jusqu'ici véritablement efficace
pour lutter contre les sorties sèches
puisque 78% des personnes incarcérées
sortent sans aucun contrôle chiffre qui
atteint 98%
pour les personnes condamnées à moins de
six mois il faudra préalablement la
sortie obtenir un logement entamé des
procédures difficile pour obtenir un rsa
une carte vitale ainsi articuler la
politique pénitentiaire et les
politiques sociales
car comme le dit denis salas le récit du
récit divise n'est pas une figure de
l'incorrigible mais celui qui attend
qu'on l'aide dans sa vulnérabilité et
qu'on le reconnaisse dans sa demande de
droits sociaux ainsi ce projet de loi
tente il à convertir la prison en chance
pour la réinsertion
l'objectif est clair réduire le risque
de récidive
à nous de rappeler à l'opinion que
l'inflation législative et l'enfermement
comme réponse pénale dissuasive n'ont
pas réussi à endiguer la récidive s'ils
à l'incarcération apporte une sécurité
provisoire seule une version réussie
renforce la sécurité à long terme je
veux ici rendre hommage au travail de
nos collègues de l'assemblée et
notamment des écologistes qui ont
beaucoup amélioré le texte parmi les
nombreuses avancées je citerai la
création à l'article 10 18 quelques
pièces d'une procédure de demande de
mise en liberté pour motif médical au
bénéfice des personnes placées en
détention provisoire
disposition qui reprend les termes d'une
proposition de loi écologie cette part
hélène lipietz est adoptée à l'unanimité
par le sénat en février dernier dont
j'ai été la rapporteure le texte issu de
la commission des lois du sénat en
montrait que son rapporteur socialiste
jean-pierre michel dont je salue ici
l'excellence de la contribution et les
écologistes portent des combats communs
se trouvant sur nombre d'amendements
aussi avec les communistes ainsi la
suppression des tribunaux correctionnels
pour mineurs délinquants ou la
suppression de la rétention de sûreté
nous voterons donc ce texte mais je vous
exhorte mes chers collègues je nous
exhorte quand bien même certains de nos
points de vue divergent aurait à nous
rassembler autour de ce texte un texte
rompant avec l'imaginaire collectif
binaire qui divise le monde en coupables
d'un côté et de l'autre des victimes qui
ne sont nullement oublié dans ce texte
l'autre avec un grand a ne l'oublions
pas c'est encore nous mêmes ne
sacrifions pas donc ce texte à la fois
humaniste et réaliste sur l'autel de nos
clivages politiques merci
voilà pour le début de la discussion
générale sur la réforme pénale qui s'est
donc déroulée hier soir au sénat vous
l'avez vu les intervenants étaient
relativement modérée lors de cette
discussion qui s'est interrompu en plein
milieu de la discussion en général cette
dernière va donc reprendre cet après
midi à 14h30 il y aura ensuite l'examen
des article je vous rappelle que le
texte a été considérablement durcie par
la commission des lois notamment sur un
point sur la contrainte pénale vous
pouvez toujours voir et revoir toutes
les séances sur notre site sur
publicsenat.fr prochain rendez vous de
l'actualité parlementaire à 19h pour 24
heures sénat le journal présenté par
delphine girard qui reviendra bien sûr
sur la réforme pénale très bonne journée
sur les chaînes parlementaires